Tudo
True nullw
Sau esto
Wird man wieder zeit
Also
Ich
Wurde ich muss euch was sagen
Irgendwie
Ich weiß nicht woran es liegt keine ahnung
Mir tut unten links bisschen der zahn weh. Ich habe keine ahnung warum
Also man sieht auch nix und habe ich mir gedacht ey
Weißt du was bevor du da jetzt lang rumfackelst rufst du mal dein zahnarzt an lässt einfach mal gucken
Ja, vielleicht muss man ich muss mir einfach nur ein bisschen zahnstein weg machen oder so keine ahnung und dann habe ich geguckt und dann festgestellt
Der hat um 12 Uhr zugemacht
Ja, aber es ist noch so extrem schlimm ist es jetzt kann ich es ist auch schon wieder besser
Vielleicht sind wir auch was an zahnfleisch oder so aber es ist nervig auf jeden fall dass
Das das ätzende an so zahngeschichten oder generell sachen im mund ist ja
dass
Das gar nicht so extrem weh tut aber das ist halt so permanent immer mal wieder und das geht halt das nervt halt ultra
halt hütsch
sagt
Hütsch im 16 monate hütsch kann ich kein kotztrieb ich bin so müde heute ich bin so kaputt das kriege ich nicht hin aber für die
call of duty fans gibt es einmal
So ja
Ja, jutsch im 16 16 monate übelst hier massive nice subscription
Das ist ja quasi schon wo habe ich
Ja, das neue call of duty näher ich war ja dumm ich habe es vorbestellt
Richtig also ich habe es nein dass ich vorbeteil ich habe es quasi vorbestellt dass ich die alpha spielen könnte
Und jetzt habe ich es halt und ich habe es noch nicht installiert
Ich habe extra geguckt ob sie irgendwelche g2a gibt übrigens wisst ihr was wir jetzt mal zusammen nachgucken
aber die musik ein bisschen leiser ist sie lauter
Ein bisschen bisschen bisschen krasse die musik hier
Übrigens ich wisst ihr was ich muss mein sound wieder einstellen ich höre mich bestimmt total
Übersteuert anders liegt daran weil teams war es ein bisschen
Stimmt total übersteuert anders liegt daran weil teams mal wieder
Meins ja guckt euch an teams hat mal wieder mein sound umgestellt
Das ist unglaublich fehl dieses programm
Und ich kann nichts dagegen machen es gibt noch nicht mal eine option dafür dass man das umstellt
Ne man kann das nicht abbestellen wenn man das pre-ordert das hat sich hier activision gedacht wenn man das pre-ordert
Dann kannst du es nicht wieder abbestellen die haben sich gedacht true lul weh
Co-comrade leute jetzt habt ihr gelitten jetzt müsst ihr ja hier
Jetzt müsst ihr ob ihr wollt oder nicht
Teams macht es halt so damit es für daus gut funktioniert ja schon
Aber man können trotzdem nur optionen einbauen bitte nicht das mikrofon des systems anfassen wäre ja eine möglichkeit
Also du bengut auf das mikrofon das ist ja eine möglichkeit
Und dann hat man auch die möglichkeit das mikrofon das ist ja eine möglichkeit
Aber das ist ja eine möglichkeit
Also du bengut aufmachen
Beste beste sei besser seitenarme ich finde ich kann also ich kann mittlerweile verstehen
Warum es sowie also warum es viele leute gibt die nicht gerne bei china seiten bestellen
Weil wenn guckt euch mal diese seite an also objektiv betrachtet sieht die nicht sonderlich vertrauenserweckend aus oder
Das sieht aus wie eine scammer phishing seite
Die sieht übelst skammer aus die seite
Aliexpress ist auch nicht viel besser
Aber aber ein bisschen besser bald ist die 11.11 zugabe
Ist klar die 11.11 zugabe die brauche ich auch schon immer was ist denn die 11.11 zugabe
Eine zahnbürste ahja ja das verbinde ich eindeutig mit 11.11 zugabe ganz klar was sonst ich denke mal ja auch chat
Eine millionen dings gewinnen easy easy money
Ja man muss schon mal ehrlich sagen so wahnsinnig vertrauenserweckend sieht die seite jetzt nicht aus
Die seite sie einfach fast gleich na ja ich finde aliexpress ist nicht ganz so voll geklatscht man erkennt schon einiges
Ähnlich ja aber aber ich mein bengun ist wer auch wer auch
Halbwegs halbwegs geht es gibt erst die spam nicht ganz so rum
Wobei man sagen muss ich habe ihr das gefühl diese ganzen asia shop seiten die haben alle ein designer das sieht schon
relativ wenig aus das wahrscheinlich das
Staatliche ministerium für web für webseiten shop design oder so und das macht es halt überall die haben dann ein wordpress eine wordpress vorlage
Und die wird dann leicht angepasst
Die die gibt es auch noch genau die gibt es ja auch noch die habe ich die vergesse ich immer da bestelle ich so wenig
Da bestelle ich so wenig die vergesse ich immer wieder
Ah
Exzellent das brauche ich jetzt also natürlich die hose ja klar so
Ja chat ich wollte irgendwas sagen aber ich habe es jetzt voll verdrängt achso ich wollte die musik leiser waren
Vielleicht ist das nicht ja
Aber ich doch ich glaube verhältnis stimme musik ist ok so
Ne wish wish also wish
Das also das kann ich nicht verstehen wie man da wie man das bestellt weil wish ist quasi
china in
scheiße
Aber so gemacht dass es auch noobs bestellen können also das ist quasi das ist quasi alles was schlecht an china ist
so gemacht dass es
Kack noobs bestellen können also wish ist totaler gott
Also also das kann ich nicht verstehen wie wir wir haben uns ja letztes mal ein fake account auf wish gemacht um zu gucken was es da so gibt
Das ist wirklich einfach nur aliexpress und banggood in schlecht, aber halt so dass die leute denken sie bestellen irgendwie aus deutschland oder
sonst wo dabei ist das ja gar nicht so das mag vielleicht irgendwie eine deutsche beschreibung haben mit schlechtem deutsch und eine
Irgendwie den absender der angeblich hier ist aber das ist ja alles so drop shipping
Also sprich die typen auf wish die bestellen ja gar nicht wirklich
Also dann bestellt er gar nicht wirklich bei den typen auf wish
Sondern man bestellt bei den typen auf wish in irgendeinem china shop und die schicken das noch nicht mal
Also die geben den auftrag nur weiter an den china shop und der schickt dann durch
Also richtig richtig hängen geblieben
Also wer da bestellt der weiß da weiß ich auch nicht weiter wish kann es komplett klingen
Bekommt man auf der china seite eine ps5 das ist eine gute frage
Die ps5 ist bestimmt verboten in china in china ist alles verboten
Nein
Aber eine ps4 kriegt man bei aliexpress immerhin was kosten eigentlich die ps5 jetzt
Also bevor ich mir eine playstation 5 oder bevor ich mir eine xbox ich hab weiß gar nicht wie die wie die aktuell überhaupt heißt
Xbox series x ist glaube ich die aktuelle bevor ich mir eine neue playstation in xbox bestell
Dann kaufe ich mir einen rechner mit 3090 rtx
5900 x und
64 g ram und und allem da kaufe ich mir einen rechner mit 3090 rtx
Die ram und und allem da kaufe ich mir irgendwann noch noch also bevor ich das mache
Oh, it's currently unavailable. Wollen wir mal gucken ob es so xbox gibt
Bestimmt in deutschland mag keiner xbox
Oh, it's unavailable
Xbox series x ist das die alte jetzt
Ist die xbox series x und die xbox series
s
Nee, was ist da der unterschied?
Nee, typico hat sich nicht gemeldet wegen meinem tweet
Ach, das ist die alt das ist diese digital only hier unten
Ohne ohne laufwerk. Ah ja stimmt okay
Gibt es die irgendwo noch also nicht dass ich jetzt eine kaufen will ich guck nur mal
Gucken wir mal gucken wir mal playstation
Fünf also wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreibt
Keine angebote keine rib gibt es nicht. Oh doch mal hier. Nee, vorbeiß
Das gibt es nicht ich ich habe mir damals bei der xbox 360
Da wollte ich ja unbedingt eine eine haben
Und da gab es auch gerade keine da habe ich mir damals mein einziges fifa gekauft
Es gab noch den fifa bundle und ich habe mir damals den fifa bundle gekauft mit frag mich nicht fifa 2008 oder so 2010
Oder irgendwas
Ich habe es nie aufgemacht nie gespielt nie beachtet, aber ich habe einen fifa bundle gekauft damals
Einziges fifa was ich mir gekauft habe
Einziges fifa was ich mir gekauft habe was otto xbox x excellent chat
Ich bin ja übrigens begeistert dass otto noch irgendwie die waren ja mal pleite von paar jahren
Das oder wahrscheinlich gehören die jetzt mittlerweile fragt mich nicht ikea oder so keine ah aber dass otto den den
Die kurve zum online handel noch gekriegt hat otto wie wie wie hießen die typen denn otto quelle
Neckermann war das früher das waren so die die kann immer an die omas kataloge verschickt haben und die haben sich dann da
strumpfhosen bestellt oder was auch immer man sich da so bestellt hat was keine ahnung ich habe dann ich habe nie katalog bestellt
Und die haben komplett den anschluss verloren
Was gibt es gibt es hier noch
nicht qualle
Ja ok die gibt es auch noch ein komisch komisch komisch noch ein stonks logo und die haben komplett den anschluss verloren
Was online online shops angeht und dann waren sie irgendwann pleite und außer anscheinend otto die haben noch irgendwie die kurve gekriegt aber wahrscheinlich
Gibt es nur noch den namen und die gehören gar nicht mehr denen die es ursprünglich da mal gehört hat oder so keine
Weiß nicht wem die jetzt gehört
Obbei die genau die hatten ja auch mehr aber gut hier gibt es auch noch eine xbox excellent lieferung aber eine playstation haben wir nicht mehr
Garantiert nicht weil in deutschland sind playstations immer instant weg die deutschen sind immer
weg die deutschen sind übelste playstation fanboys
Ergibt es nicht das war aber schon immer so deutschland war übel war richtig
Fuck was ist denn los heute mit mir mich juckt es am auge
Und ich drücke so ein bisschen hier aus auge und juck mich und es tut übelst weh was ist denn los bin ich jetzt gerade am
am max broken oder ist kaputt
Grip f
Bald ist vorbei
Nix mehr
Ja so gehen wir mal kurz auf amazon ich euch nehme ich mal was zeigen ich habe nämlich mal wieder
Was bestellt was wir im stream ausprobieren können
Ihr kennt mich erkennt mich wenn ich steckdosen leisten sehe die man flaschen kann mit custom firmware
Ich kann mich nicht zurückhalten
Ich habe mittlerweile glaube ich acht steckdosen brauche ich im leben nicht
Im leben brauche ich den nicht so und ich habe mal wieder neue steckdosen bestellt jemand angeblich mit das motor flaschen kann
also ihr wisst ja steckdosen leisten
steckdosen leisten da
Die müssen bei mir alle mit custom firmen betrieben werden
Und generell dieses custom firmen flaschen
Das ist gar nicht mal gar nicht mal so doof
Viele sagen immer max warum flascht du custom firmen und das ist doch total sinnlos
Nehmen doch einfach das normale was ist der vorteil von custom firmen ich habe ich habe es euch ja letzten schon gezeigt
Aber zum beispiel sowas kannst du nur mit custom firmen
Leute ich stelle euch mal vor ich war übrigens letztens wieder
Und an der sonne kann man sich gar nicht richtig vorstellen oder
Ich meine es war knapp ich weiß ich habe es ich habe es gerade so überlebt
so
Genau guckt mal also so unsinnig ist das ganze gar nicht
Ich habe hier ich zeige ich ich zeige euch jetzt nicht das video wahrscheinlich haben sie mein wahrscheinlich haben sie meist schon gesehen wo ich das
Letzte mal gezeigt habe aber ich habe hier in meinem bad
Habe ich hier so ein heizlufter wenn es kühl ist kann man anmachen weil halt kalt und heiz und brauche
so und hier achtung
Spule mal ein bisschen vor ja ja ich erkläre gerade noch so guck mal hier habe ich jetzt in nfc tag
Wenn ich jetzt mein iphone nehme
und an den nfc tag halte
Dann triggert iphone nfc tag erkannt
das triggert shortcuts und shortcuts sendet ja ja ich ich ich
Spiegeln mich öfters mal irgendwo und dann gibt es dann max max fps liegt aus der suppe war mein persönliches lieblings
reveal video
allerbeste so und dann geht das ganze hier über shortcuts über home assistant
Und dann über home assistant pass mal auf also jetzt kann man an und aus machen dann geht der heizlufter an und aus wenn man das da
Dran hält und das ganze guckt jetzt geht er an und das ganze geht nur dass das falsche
Weil ich diese steckdose mit custom firmware geflasht habe
Das iphone x kann kein nfc text legen wirklich also ich habe habe ich nicht auch ein iphone x
An ich habe ein iphone doch ich habe xs glaube ich xr
xr
Ne ich weiß es gar nicht jetzt ihr wisst das immer besser was ich habe ich glaube ich habe den xr
Ja genau ich habe eins was
Keine 50 kameras draußen hat
Oder ob er jetzt ihr erkennt das doch bestimmt was ist das für ein iphone hier was ist das was ist das hier
Erkennt man das irgendwie erkennt das der apple profi was das ist
Ich habe ganz ich glaube das ist ein xr
Ich glaube das ist ein xr warum hatten das xr
einen nfc tag und ein anderes x nicht egal apple
Apple logik so zumindest das ganze funktioniert nur
Weil ich diese steckdose hier custom firmware geflasht habt ist der einzige grund warum das funktioniert
Also man sieht custom firmware flaschen bringt es. Ach ja und der eigentliche vorteil ist
Man braucht keine china cloud für das ist eigentlich der allergrößte vorteil man hat ein web interface und sowas aber
Das ist halt der größte vorteil braucht nicht die offizielle china app man braucht generell keine china cloud und man kann es ein
Einbinden wie man wie man will hier übrigens leute jetzt muss ich gerade noch mal eine sache los ich habe mich ja voll
Es muss unbedingt mal irgendeine gambling glücksspiel seite müsste so eine so eine
einen
twitter
Twitter hashtag wetten machen annehmen also sprich dass man drauf wetten kann was morgen für hashtags trennten
Da wäre ich wäre reich wenn die das machen ich kann mittlerweile
So quasi twitter empörung auf zwei bis drei tage im voraus predikten
Ich sehe einen clip ich sehe irgendwas und ich weiß
Das wird für empörung sorgen auf twitter und zu 90 prozent ist das auch so
Das müsste echt einer mal so eine wettseite machen da wette ich jeden tag auf twitter tags und wird reich twitter hastags
Neues codeprojekt das problem ist glaube ich gar nicht mal so die seite zu programmieren sondern das
Rechtlich und insgesamt alles gut zu gut zu machen
Ja war ich auch wieder witzig fand ich habe heute
Ihr wisst ja ich habe meinen mein twitter habe ich auf andorra stehen
Sieht man jetzt hier nicht aber ich habe mein twitter auf andorra stehen dass ich mir diesen diesen ganzen müll hier
Die ganzen müll tags in deutschland nicht geben muss
Und heute morgen ich mache ab und zu mal twitter auf so auf anonymen und gucke was in deutschland trendet
Sehe ich so aha nur trendet wieder und das ist ja immer wenn der typ trendet dann hat er irgendwas vom stapel gelassen wo sich ganz twitter wieder empört
Und ich habe mir den clip angeguckt ich will jetzt gar nicht zu sehr drauf rumreiten
Wir müssen gleich gleich noch ein paar sachen einkaufen aber ich habe mir den clip angeguckt und als ich diesen clip gesehen habe wo sie
Ich wusste ich twitter wird eskalieren die die drehen wieder voll am rad
Also hashtag draufgeguckt was ist twitter ist komplett am eskalieren komplett
durch
komplett durch ja im kopf
Man könnte man könnte jetzt eigentlich sagen
Wenn er wenn er das schafft mit so einer was ist denn das ich gucke das nicht was ist das
So eine art satire sendung oder sowas keine ahnung also wenn er das schafft mit dieser sendung so viel
Kontroverse auszulösen da kann er zumindest diesen teil seines jobs gar nicht so schlecht machen weil es scheint ja zu funktionieren
Ich gucke mir das nicht an ich habe diesen clip gesehen manche sachen waren halt
Belegbar schwachsinn wie dass dieses buch in usa erschienen ist aber mir war klar die leute gehen total drauf ab und was ich ja nicht verstehe ist
warum sind
Alle aktuellen so geil drauf sich über irgendwas aufzuregen kann man nicht einfach
irgendwie sich mit dem irgendwie damit abfinden dass
Heute lacht man über irgendwas und morgen lachen halt mal andere überein so solange sich das in der waage hält ist doch alles okay
Aber nee das geht nicht
Da muss man da erst mal hier
Den weltuntergang ausrufen wenn da was ist ich ich habe auch das gefühl jetzt wo corona ist den leuten ist noch langweiliger
Und die können sich noch mehr aufregen über so einen kacke
Es ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht wert sich da drüber aufzuregen aber die gehen da ab immer. Oh meine güde
also
Die sind auch da setzt auch echt bei allen komplett komplett der verstand aus wenn es um irgendwie so ihre ihre lieblingsthemen geht
Was wo bloß du alte iot basler hast du ahnung von guten funken standards beziehungsweise protokoll für sie
Ja ja ja habe ich da gibt es aber eigentlich nur eins da gibt es eigentlich nur eins was sinnvoll sinnvoll nutzbar ist und das ist laura
Jetzt ist er und natürlich wobei stimmt nicht das stimmt nicht was ich gesagt habe es gibt zwei die sinnvoll nutzbar ist und das ist laura
Ne laura brauchst du kannst du selbst machen habe ich auch selbst gemacht also wenn du alter iot basler bist dann ist das kein problem
Also es gibt die sache einmal bei laura zu machen oder
mit einer simkarte
Also das ist gar nicht mal so teuer wo davon datentarif
iot das ist gar nicht mal so teuer mit einer simkarte
Ich glaube 2 euro im monat oder so da fuck
Können die da nicht einfach mal eine preisliste machen
Ich habe letztens was gefunden
Prepaid datentarife
Moment wo war das denn?
Ich weiß es nicht
Prepaid datentarife Moment wo war das denn?
iot simtarif
Was war das? Telefonica war das gar nicht mal davon
Ja genau also keine ahnung
So hier iot deutschland 12 monate anzahl simkarten 1
Datenpakete pro sim keine ahnung 5
So
Ich mein
1.39 das ist ok
10 euro für 10 jahre
Was 10 euro für 10 jahre moment wo?
Also 10 euro für 10 jahre würde ich sofort kaufen
Wo steht das mit 10 euro für 10 jahre?
Telekom iot ah Moment news
Nee das ist schon
Ich weiß es nicht
stressful
Können wir auch gleich mal gucken.
Ja, also, ähm, neben Laura, zu Laura sag ich gleich was, weil ich hab schon was in Laura gebaut, sogar im Stream haben wir das gemacht.
Moment.
Äh, Twitter.
Ah, ich hab nämlich mal ein Bild gepostet von dieser Kiste, wie das bei mir ausschaut mit dem Laura Gateway.
So, also erstmal gucken, was wollen die denn hier.
Es gibt 10 Euro pro Unit, Specifications, okay.
Was ist da, was ist da drinnen?
Java Card?
Ernsthaft?
Ich hoffe mal, das hat mit Java nichts zu tun, sonst will ich die nicht.
Ja, genau, Axi.
Aber wie gesagt, das geht ja nicht um mich, ich hatte eine gerade im Chat gefragt.
So, ähm, wo steht denn jetzt, was da drinnen ist?
Bin ich jetzt doof?
Wo steht es denn jetzt, was da dabei ist?
Over the Air Update über SMS.
Adware Features?
Ja, was ist denn da jetzt dabei?
Ich kapier's nicht.
Flatrate, SIM-Karte.
Hä?
Die Seiten sind so kompliziert, das ist zu, bin ich zu low-brained für.
Flatrate, aha, hier, hier.
10 Euro für 10 Jahre?
Ey, das ist Poggers.
Das ist ziemlich nice.
Ich hab mir auch erst letztens ein Board gekauft mit SIM.
Ja, also, um nochmal zu dieser Sache mit einem Kilometer Funkstandards zu kommen.
Also, es gibt meiner Meinung nach zwei Varianten, die man machen kann.
Entweder über LoRa oder über SIM.
LoRa hat den Vorteil, man kann deutlich low-powerige Boards,
also man bekommt wohl deutlich mehr low-power Boards mit LoRa als mit SIM-Karte.
Mit SIM-Karte fällt mir da jetzt zumindest von den üblichen Verdächtigen,
ESP 82, ESP 86 nur eins ein und das ist nicht so extrem low-power,
als dass es sich für Batterie eignen würde.
So, und, ähm, mit LoRa hab ich dieses Ding als Gateway.
Mach ich mal das Image.
Dieses Teil hab ich als Gateway bei uns.
Da hab ich ein 3D-Case ausgedruckt und hab das Ding unter das Dach gestellt.
Das ist als Gateway vollkommen ausreichend.
Das kostet ja auch nicht die Welt.
Das kostet 16 Euro auf Banggood.
Also diese 150 Euro Gateways ist total übertrieben.
Ähm, genau.
Und dann brauchst du noch irgendeinen Client halt.
Und da hab ich einen ESP 32 Fire Beetle mit einem LoRa-Modul dran.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist nicht sonderlich gut für eine Batterie.
Das ist für ein Gateway gut.
Das hat... Moment, ist das überhaupt das richtige Board?
Also genau, ich hab da noch ein Display dran.
Richtig, richtig, genau.
Ich würd's dir zeigen...
Ich würd's dir zeigen, wenn ich wüsste, wo ich's hab.
Warte mal, ich mach dir mal ein Foto.
Warte mal, ich glaub, ich weiß, wo's ist.
Ja, also...
Ehrlich gesagt, da vorne ein Foto machen weiß ich ja nicht, ob sich das jetzt wirklich großartig lohnt,
weil ich hab die Antenne nicht dran.
Das sieht gar nicht so cool aus, wie's dann halt aussieht so.
Ähm...
Hab auch keinen Strom dran und so.
Ich mach dir trotzdem mal kurz ein Foto.
So...
Wobei... Moment.
Moment, ich stream das einfach, ich hab doch die Kamera.
Moment, Leute.
Exzellent.
Wo ist mein iPhone mit der Kamera?
Passt mal auf, jetzt mal hier.
High Interactive Big Brain Stream.
Ich muss das iPhone holen.
Warte mal.
So, also Fingerreveal, genau.
Also, ich mach jetzt mal den Livestream an vom iPhone.
In der Hoffnung, ich schmeiß den wieder nicht wieder die Hälfte runter hier.
So.
Full C.
Wo hab ich denn Livestream?
Wo ist es denn?
Hier?
Kamera?
Zack.
So, ich mach's mal an.
So, ähm...
Ja, ich kann's auch in OBS einbinden, aber so ist einfacher.
So, also.
Genau, jetzt kann ich dir das zeigen, und zwar...
Ich hab jetzt leider keine Antenne dran, aber du kannst das wahrscheinlich ungefähr vorstellen, denk ich.
Ich mach jetzt mal Alibi mit.
Genau.
Na, guck mal.
Also, das ist das Case.
Das ist das Case.
Durch das Case hab ich selbst ausgedruckt.
Da drinnen ist quasi das Board, was ich dir eben gezeigt hab.
Also sprich, äh, ne?
Das ist das Board, und...
Aufmachen kann ich es jetzt nicht, weil ich hab...
...servererweise zugeschraubt.
Aber das Teil...
...das stellst du dir einfach...
...und dann kannst du deine ganzen Laura...
...deine ganzen Laura-Dinger kannst du...
...damit ansprechen.
Naja, gut.
Wenn du Gateway meinst, du meinst dieses...
...Things Network.
Das kannst du damit auch machen.
Aber hab ich nicht.
Ich mein, wozu auch?
Ich bewege mich innerhalb von einem Kilometer.
Ich brauch keine...
Wie heißt das?
The Things Network oder so?
Jaja, End to End geht.
Ich hab das schon ausprobiert.
Ich hab auf dem Friedhof einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor...
...versucht zu installieren und zu kommunizieren.
Und das war so ungefähr 1,2 Kilometer weg.
Das ging.
Allerdings nur auf dem langsamsten Modus.
So, und ich hab noch ein Display dran gemacht.
Da sieht man, glaub ich, dann die Empfangsstärke oder sowas.
Ich mach mal kurz Strom rein.
Mal gucken, was dann auf dem Display kommt.
Ich hatte das ewig nicht mal an.
Jaja, das Laura ist übelst nice.
Das kriegst du bis zu 10 Kilometer...
...auf weiter bei Sichtlinie wohlgemerkt.
Und umso höher man ist, umso besser.
Auch mal kurz irgendein USB-Kabel zum Anmachen.
Fäustet.
Angehen tut es nicht.
Ja gut, keine Ahnung, was ich da gebaut hab.
Warum das Display nicht angeht.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich hatte es jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mal im Betrieb.
Ich mach wieder ab.
Zack.
Und ich schließ mal mein iPhone kurz ans Ladegerät an, falls man das nochmal braucht.
So.
Exzellent.
Also.
Wisst ihr, da sagt mal einer, ich würde nicht auf den Chat eingehen oder sowas.
Genau.
Aber das ist auch dem, die mich interessiert.
Ich gebe zu, manchmal gehe ich nicht auf den Chat an, wenn es so Sachen sind, wo ich
keinen Bock hab, drüber zu reden.
Aber ansonsten muss man sagen, haben wir hier schon wirklich ziemlich viel Chat-Interaktion
und auch wirklich viel hilfsbereite Leute im Chat.
Ich hab's das letzte Mal gesagt.
Also ich bin der Meinung, ich hab den besten Chat.
Und jetzt ohne zu schleimen, es ist unglaublich selten, dass man auf Twitch das Ganze sieht,
dass die Leute im Chat nicht untereinander rummieben und untereinander rumtrollen.
Ich meine, das machen wir natürlich auch.
So ist das nicht.
Das gehört auf Twitch dabei.
Aber hier helfen sich die Leute wirklich auch im Chat.
Es ist echt nice.
Was war das für Door-Cam im Bild?
Äh, was?
Was meinst du?
Hast du noch einen Namen für das Image?
Ich hab das selbst programmiert.
Hab ich nicht, nein.
Ich hab, ich kann ja auch noch nicht mal mehr sagen, ehrlich gesagt, was ich für eine
Library verwendet hab.
Ja, danke für den Prime-Sub übrigens.
Exzellent.
Ja, genau, also IoT-Sim.
Also ich muss sagen, das finde ich echt gut.
Zehn Euro für zehn Jahre flat, da kann man wirklich was machen.
Das ist zum Beispiel so was, wenn man einen Tracker im Auto haben will, der nur GPS
trackt, ab und zu mal.
Da kommt man mit 500 MB wahrscheinlich halbwegs hin, denke ich mal.
XXX oder...
Twitch, Brian, exquisite subscription, danke schön.
Im Bild als LOL, also Dom PC, ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was du meinst.
Was haben die denn für eine Taktung?
Ähm, die, die, die, die Dinger.
Ke Ahnung, 240 Mhz, Dualcore 240 Mhz oder so.
Ja, also wenn das natürlich nur 500 MB für zehn Jahre sind, da muss man ganz schön
sparsam sein.
Ach, die Taktung meinst du ja, da müsste man tatsächlich mal gucken.
Aber sag mal mal so, mal angenommen, man möchte wirklich so eine Art GPS-Tracker
machen.
Dann brauchste, ich würd mal sagen so, was braucht man denn da?
So einen Request, so einen Kilobyte pro Request oder so?
Ähm, Moony kann ich wirklich nicht viel zu sagen.
Äh, ich hab bei mir einen Keystone-Panel, aber das, ja, ich hab da keinen Großteil.
Also wenn man ungefähr einen Kilobyte pro Request annimmt.
So, das kommt ja ungefähr hin.
Was ist GPS-Koordinaten großartig?
Das sind Koordinaten, Längengrad, Breitengrad, Höhe vielleicht noch.
Also da kommst du mit einem Kilobyte pro Request bestimmt gut hin.
Da kommt noch ein bisschen HTTP oder so vielleicht dabei, aber da kommt man wahrscheinlich mit
einem Kilobyte pro Request ganz gut hin.
So, Kilobyte, dann sag mal mal, du machst am Tag irgendwie, mach man dann am Tag so 10,
10, ähm, ja gut, nee, eigentlich musst du das machen je nachdem.
Kannst auch mal 20, 20, 20 Dinge am Tag machst du, also sprichst du 20 Kilobyte, 20 Kilobyte
am Tag, 20 Kilobyte, so und dann brauchst du im Jahr 365, äh, 20 mal, so.
So, dann brauchst du 7 Kilobyte im Jahr, das sind 7,3 MB.
Da kommst du doch, da kommst du doch locker mit hin.
Meinst du nicht, ein Kilobyte Request reicht?
Doch, guck mal, Kilobyte ist ganz schön viel.
Ich mein, man muss es ja nicht über HTTP machen, über HTTP kommt das ganze Heddergedöns und
so noch dabei.
Ja, doch, das könnte, könnte hinkommen.
Also, das ist ein echt interessantes Angebot, das kannte ich noch nicht, das ist wirklich,
das ist echt nice.
Also, für solche Anwendungsgebiete, wie ich eben gerade beschrieben hab, ist das nix.
Also, äh, Ultra Low Power und SIM ist schwierig, aber wofür das zum Beispiel gut ist, beispielsweise
um Autos zu tracken oder sowas, oder, oder irgendwas, wo halt ein Stromanschluss ist,
glaub ich ganz gut.
So, aber das ist wirklich nice, das gefällt mir.
So, kann das jeder kaufen oder muss man da irgendwie 500 Stück abnehmen oder sowas?
Äh, äh, Moni, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, was LSA Plus ist.
Ist das Glasfaser Zeug?
Ohne LSA Plus, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Äh, iiih, was denn das?
Wie gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Jaja, also kann das jeder kaufen, das mag nur, weil ich will das jetzt, mag nur, weil ich
will das jetzt kaufen.
China Plus, exellent.
Guck mal, man kann sogar rebooken.
So, wie?
Okay, buy, buy, okay.
Ach, das ist das schon.
Das ist, one, ten years, 500 MB, das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Nee, kenn ich nicht, Sebaro.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
So, mal angenommen, man bestellt jetzt da zehn, zahlt mal 100 Euro.
Das ist doch eigentlich, ist das nice.
Ich find das richtig gut.
Ich bin jetzt ernsthaft am Überlegen, ob ich nicht irgendwelche Dinger mit SIM-Karte bastel.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Ich hab mir ja letztens dieses SIM-Karten-Board bestellt.
Ähm, hier, wartet mal, das da.
PTGO SIM.
Nee, T, T-Call ist das, glaub ich.
T, T-Go, T-Anruf.
Das Teil hab ich mir letztens bestellt.
Und das hat halt ein SIM-Karten-Slot dabei.
Aber ich hab mir nur eins bestellt, weil ich wollte es mal ausprobieren.
Das heißt, ich hab sogar ein Board mit SIM-Karte da.
Also ich bin, ich bin da jetzt wirklich, ich bin kurz davor, mir da mal eine zu bestellen.
Und ihr kennt mich, Leute, ihr wisst, ich bestell nie eine, ich bestell immer mindestens drei.
Nein.
Hau eh nicht.
Ich find das ist cool.
Das hat was.
Und warum kostet es Shipping?
Ihh.
Ah, das G-Bate.
Kommt noch Mehrwertsteuer drauf.
Hat das GPS?
Moment, hat das hier GPS?
By the way, der, der eben gefragt hat, nee, ich glaub, das hat das an GPS.
By the way, der, der eben gefragt hat wegen diesem LoRa-Board, das hat GPS drauf.
Das ist ein richtig guter, nennen wir es mal, richtig guter Gateway oder Endpunkt für sowas.
Das ist echt praktisch.
Du hast GPS drin und LoRa drin.
Weißt du, du kannst Zeit abrufen.
Ich wollte mir damit schon mal einen NTP sauber bauen.
So einfach, weil es geht mit GPS-Uhr, aber totaler Schwachsinn.
Wozu?
Genau, und das Ding hier hat einen Anschluss für Batterie, SIM-Karte und halt eine Antenne,
die man draußen dranpappen kann.
Die Sache ist die, es ist nicht extrem low power.
Es ist, wobei, ist ja mal so, wir können das mit GPS machen.
GPS, so ein GPS-Modul kostet ja nicht so viel.
Das kostet wahrscheinlich 6 Euro oder sowas.
Hier, GPS, GPS-Modul.
Nein, Rust, du kannst theoretisch in Rust programmieren, aber das ist noch sehr alpha.
Du musst höchstwahrscheinlich mit C++ ran.
Dafür kannst du Arduino benutzen.
So.
Das ist powered bei Telekom, wirklich?
Ist mir doch wurscht, von wem die powered sind.
Übrigens Leute, ich hab das jetzt gemacht.
Wir haben letztens im Stream dieses Angebot von 1&1 gesehen.
Ich weiß, 1&1 und...
Ja, man kann sich da lang drüber lustig machen.
Und ich hab mir jetzt zum Test meinen Server gekauft bei 1&1.
Und zwar...
Nein, nein, kein WordPress.
Wo ist er denn?
In 1 Euro, 1, 1, 1 Euro Server hab ich mir gekauft.
Bin ich jetzt blöd?
VPS-Hosting.
Z-Packages.
Zwei?
Was? Nein, nein, nein.
Es.
Zwei im Monat? Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Nein, es hat eins gekostet, immer 20, genau.
Wo ist es denn? Hier Server?
VPS?
Hier, den hab ich mir gekauft.
Und da ist mir was aufgefallen beim Einrichten.
Und zwar, wenn man sich das kaufen will,
die sind nicht so wirklich zeitgemäß,
was Cloud und Server angeht.
Das war dein Mitbewohner, ah, verstehe.
Exzellent.
So, und wenn man das kaufen will,
dann wird einem nämlich irgendwann auffallen,
dass die einen gleich für 12 Monate in Beschlag nehmen wollen.
Also die haben das so mit Cloud und On Demand noch nicht so ganz kapiert.
Bei anderen Anbietern kannst du nämlich Server erstellen und gleich wieder ausmachen.
Aber ja, ich verstehe, warum die das machen.
Ein Euro ist wirklich ziemlich günstig.
Wenn du dir mal anguckst, bei Hetzner kostet es, glaube ich,
den ganzen Monat laufen zu lassen, sie barren.
Du weißt das besser, du hast letztens die Sachen gekauft bei Hetzner.
Wahrscheinlich kostet es bei Hetzner irgendwie 3,50 oder so.
Und wenn man das den ganzen Monat laufen lässt.
Oder 2,80. Aber, also, ich finde es okay.
Es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, ja, mit diesen 12 Monaten.
So, und da dachte ich mir doch, okay, weißt du was?
Gehst du mal auf einen Monat runter.
Ich mein, willst du den Server doch eigentlich einfach nur mal testen?
Und wenn man auf einen Monat runtergeht, guck mal.
Einmalige Einrichtungsgebühr 10 Euro.
Ja, also das ist eindeutig künstliches teuer machen,
dass man 12 Monate nimmt. Was anderes ist das nicht.
Weil ich meine, du hast die Auswahl 12 Monate für 12 Euro.
Oder, ähm, ein Monat für 11 Euro.
Warum sollte man das machen?
Top Deal, ja. Aber ganz im Ernst, 12 Monate, ein Euro geht in Ordnung.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, ansonsten benutze ich ja mittlerweile,
früher immer ganz viel Digital Ocean verwendet.
Aber, wenn man das mal vergleicht, äh, Pricings.
Also, wie gesagt, früher habe ich, Pricing.
Früher habe ich immer relativ viel Digital Ocean verwendet
für so On-Demand-Server, was man mal braucht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich mal OpenStreetView, nicht OpenStreetView,
äh, Open, Moment, wie heißen sie? Open, blöd, OpenStreetMaps?
Nee, OpenStreet, OpenStreetMaps, genau.
Wenn ich da mal Karten konvertieren muss,
da habe ich mir manchmal hier bei, ähm,
bei Digital Ocean habe ich mir manchmal so eine fette Kiste gemietet hier
mit irgendwie 64G, 32 CPU und sowas, dass die Sachen schnell processed waren.
Dass der Kram im Monat 640 Euro kostet, ist egal.
Weil ich bin nach 2, 3 Stunden durch und bezahle dann 2,50 Euro oder so.
Ja, das ist hier natürlich nicht so.
Aber mittlerweile bin ich hier hängen geblieben.
Das meiste, was ich mir mache, holt ich mir echt bei Hetzner.
Hetzner hat mehr oder weniger ähnliche Pakete mit Digital Ocean.
Ist hier in Deutschland, gut, Digital Ocean auch eine gute Anwendung,
da kann man nichts sagen.
Aber es kostet nur die Hälfte von Digital Ocean.
So, ähm, und hier kannst du einen Server laufen lassen für 289 den Monat.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn, ne?
Eine virtuelle CPU, 2GB RAM, aber dafür 20TB Traffic.
Damit kann man schon ein bisschen was abfackeln.
Locations, Nürnberg, Falken, Horst oder so und Finnland.
Aber das ist halt nochmal eine Ecke billiger.
Was ich raus will, ist, es ist irgendwo okay, dass die 12 Euro wollen.
Genau, das Archiv und die Website läuft auch.
Ja, Siebago, kein Problem.
Ich bin da froh, dass du dieses Archiv so gewissenhaft machst jetzt schon so lang.
Genau, aber es lohnt sich eigentlich, ist schon okay.
Und bis jetzt bin ich damit, ehrlich gesagt, auch ganz zufrieden gewesen.
NetCup hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Server.
Was haben die denn da?
Ist im Prinzip ähnlich, ist im Prinzip ähnlich.
Das nimmt sich jetzt nicht viel.
Ist ziemlich ähnlich, eine CPU, 2GB RAM, 20TB.
Bisschen mehr Traffic, aber ganz ehrlich, 20TB Traffic.
Wir haben es doch ausprobiert.
Ich hab doch bei Hetzer mal einen Speedtest Server installiert für euch.
Und wir haben das am Ende, haben wir es irgendwie geschafft, keine Ahnung, 400 MB oder so Traffic zu machen.
Und da hat der ganze Chat rumgespammt.
Tja, aber um jetzt mal nochmal schnell die Sache hier abzuschließen.
Ich bin da komplett sidetracked geworden mittlerweile.
Das finde ich richtig gut, das werde ich ausprobieren.
Ich werde mir das mal bookmarken.
Da werde ich mir drei Stück von bestellen.
Und, ja, nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht hier im Stream.
Da werde ich mir drei Stück von bestellen und mal gucken, wie weit man mit 500 MB und eine 10 Jahre SIM-Karte kommt.
Weil das ist ja mal ein Wort, 10 Jahre, 500 MB, easy.
Und wenn man wirklich davon ausgeht, dass man einen Kilobyte pro Request braucht, ungefähr über den Daumen gepeilt,
um ein bisschen GPS-Daten zu verschicken,
dann muss man halt mal zur Abwechslung ein bisschen effizient Progress machen.
Ist in Ordnung, ja.
Ist schon okay.
Und man kann das ja dann richtig big brain machen, wisst ihr?
Man kann es ja sogar so machen.
Man kann, wenn man das mal angenommen will, man legt das ins Auto
und möchte Auto GPS, also sein Auto GPS tracken oder was auch immer.
Oder das Auto vom Opa GPS tracken, dass er sich nicht verfährt oder so.
So, und da könnte man sogar, weil das schließt man ja eher an diesen 12 Volt,
12 Volt auf USB, wird man im Auto machen und das Ding irgendwo die Ecke pappen mit Heißkleber oder so.
Und dann kann man ja die Sache richtig big brain machen.
Man nimmt die SIM-Karte und dann macht man sich noch so einen Acceleration-Sensor dran.
Und dann kann man sogar quasi mitbekommen, wann das Auto beschleunigt und wann das Auto bremst.
Und wenn das Auto quasi, sagen wir, für 10 Minuten sich nicht mehr bewegt hat,
dann kann man ein GPS-Update schicken oder so.
Das wäre eigentlich eine richtig coole Sache.
Was bringt eigentlich dieses Narrowband IoT, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, keine Ahnung.
Sagt mir auch nichts.
So, ja, also, jetzt sind wir ja erstmal übel sidetracked worden.
Dann kommen wir mal zurück zu China und Einkaufen und Aliexpress.
Soll ich mal eine Liste aufmachen? Ja, Aliexpress ist gut.
Die spammen einen immer so übertrieben voll.
Genau, das ist das eine, was ich euch zeigen wollte, habe ich euch jetzt gezeigt.
Werden wir mal wieder versuchen.
Eine Batterie hast du schon recht, eine Batterie sollte man vielleicht schon reinmachen,
dass das Ding mal so ein paar Stunden überbrücken kann.
Wobei das auch nicht schlimm ist. Wozu? Wozu?
Es reicht ja, wenn es ab und zu mal angeht.
Da muss man sich mal Gedanken machen.
Ist da Traffic mit oder ohne TCP plus IP?
Das ist alles mit. Das ist ganz normal alles, was du drüber machst.
Also sprich, wenn du da jetzt HTTPS drüber machst und die Pakete größer sind
und 30 Milliarden Header dranhängst, das geht alles da rein.
Aber ich gehe trotzdem davon auf, dass man mit einem Kilobyte locker hinkommt
pro GPS Koordinaten Update.
Achso, darüber kann man das auch erkennen. Ja, stimmt.
Genau, also das probieren wir demnächst mal im Stream aus, ob man das Ding flashen kann.
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich kann nicht widerstehen, wenn es Steckdosen zum Flashen gibt.
Da wollte ich euch noch was anderes zeigen und zwar, ich muss mal kurz hochscrollen.
Übrigens Avira geht mir mega auf den Sack gerade.
Ich habe hier auf dem alten Rechner, über den ich euch hier die Vorschau habe,
wo ich den Chat sehe und sowas, habe ich ja immer noch Avira drauf.
Frag mich nicht, in welcher geistigen Umnachtung ich mich befunden habe,
dass ich da Avira drauf gemacht habe.
Das ist da schon seit vier Jahren oder so drauf, ich habe es einfach nicht runtergeschmissen.
Diese, die Kollegen hier.
Und das poppt permanent auf und erzählt mir, dass es irgendwelche unsicheren Settings gefunden hat.
Dann klickst du drauf und es ist kein Virus oder so.
Wie soll da auch drauf kommen auf den Rechner, da ist ja nichts außer Vorschau.
Und dann sagt er mir, dass ich irgendwelche unsicheren System-Settings habe oder so.
Das soll einfach mal die Klappe halten, wenn ich auf den Sack gehe.
Gibt es einen Black Friday Shopping Stream?
Wann ist denn das denn?
Nächste Woche?
Ah, 27. November.
Ja, exellent.
Soll ich euch nochmal auch was anderes sagen, was auch extrem exellent ist?
Ich muss jetzt genau noch Dienstag arbeiten, Mittwoch arbeiten und dann habe ich eine Woche,
zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, vier Wochen, fünf Wochen, sechs Wochen, sieben Wochen,
ach nee, die habe ich doppelt gezählt.
Sieben Wochen Urlaub.
Oh, Moment.
Warte.
Microsoft, warum geht der Fall nach oben nach unten?
Alter, da waren die Usability-Experten von Microsoft wieder am Start.
Also, nochmal.
Im Monat nach oben, würde ich sagen, da kommt November, wenn ich nach oben gehe,
weil es geht ja nach oben, also hoch.
Die meinen hier nach hoch scrollen, okay, das ist nicht so schön.
Ganz ehrlich, über solche Windows-Sachen mache ich mir schon keine Gedanken mehr.
So, also nochmal.
Also eine Woche, zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, vier Wochen, fünf Wochen, sechs Wochen, sieben Wochen.
Exellent.
Sieben Wochen Urlaub, so muss das sein.
Länger als Sommerferien, ja.
Sehr nice.
Dem soll ich folgen auf Twitter.
Dem Anders Serial, Alpha 4 Games und dem Commander Krieger.
Exellent.
So, genau.
Und ich wollte euch noch was anderes zeigen, weil das habe ich mir schon gekauft
und das müssen wir jetzt nicht kaufen.
Ich muss jetzt nicht im Stream faken, dass ich was kaufe, was ich schon gekauft habe.
Und zwar, ich habe angefangen mit, ich habe es glaube ich in einem letzten Stream schon erzählt,
mit ein bisschen RGB-Beleuchtung bei mir daheim.
Also, ihr wisst ja, dass ich heimautomatisierungsmäßig schon ganz fett mit dabei bin.
Also, dabei bin ich, da baue ich ja seit Jahren schon dran rum.
Aber ich habe bisher mich nie großartig für Beleuchtung interessiert.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz was, Beleuchtung.
Moment, voll C.
Ich hoffe, dass man das sieht.
So.
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht direkt zeigen, weil dann leak ich mich selbst, ja.
Aber ich kann mal das Licht ausmachen vom Handy.
So, und jetzt.
Und jetzt.
Ich habe nämlich extra mal da was vorbereitet.
Excellent.
Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboard.
Ups.
Hier, Arbeitszimmer.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich muss mal kurz den hier aufmachen, dass man es irgendwie sieht.
Das sind LiveX-Lampen.
So, ich kann jetzt hier sagen, Arbeitszimmer sind wir.
Ich muss das mal, glaube ich, ein bisschen blitzen.
Arbeitszimmer.
Also, das erste, was man machen kann, ist, man kann heller machen.
Ich glaube, ihr habt es gesehen, es ist heller, dunkler.
Also, es ist dimmbar.
Das ist jetzt ja nur wirklich kein großartiges Ding.
Das können ja viele.
So, jetzt ist quasi, mehr oder weniger, fast aus.
Jetzt wieder volle Pulle.
So, aber was richtig cool ist an den Dingern.
Erstens, die Home Assistant-Integration ist richtig nice.
Und, jetzt passt mal auf.
Man kann einstellen, welche Temperatur weiß ist.
Also, ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ich will es relativ heiß, also blau.
Dann ist es eher so.
Das Licht, wir müssen warten, bis die Kamera sich angepasst hat.
So, dann kann ich sagen, okay, ich will es jetzt eher kühl haben.
Äh, äh, nee, die Temperatur.
Oh, excellent, dann ist es eher rot.
Nee, warte mal.
Blau ist kalt, nee, blau ist heiß.
Oder?
Blau ist kalt, ernsthaft?
Aber Temperatur ist blau heiß und rot kalt.
Warum heißt es dann Temperatur?
Ja, Chet, guck mal, Temperatur.
Wo ist die, wo ist die Flamme heiß?
Am blauen oder am, am roten?
Dort, wo es blau ist.
Also, wenn ihr mal euch so einen Bunsenbrenner anguckt.
Dort, wo es blau ist, ist der am heißesten.
Nicht?
Doch, oder?
Nicht so?
So, und, und noch was?
Und noch was?
Blaues Licht ist ja auch, hat ja auch mehr Energie als rotes.
Also zumindest hat rotes Licht größere Wellenlänge als blaues.
Okay, dann ist es in dem Fall genau umgedreht.
Zumindest, man kann, man kann die, die Weißtemperatur quasi so einstellen.
So, zumindest ist es auch vollkommen egal, ob das stimmt, was ich jetzt erzählt habe,
aber ist, worüber man das nennt.
Schau mal dein Wasserhahn an.
Was hat mein Wasserhahn mit meiner Lichttemperatur zu tun?
Das muss ich jetzt nicht verstehen, oder?
Da ist blau auch immer kalt.
Ach, so meinen die das mit heiß oder blau.
Ah.
Ja, Leute, ihr müsst zugeben, dass das meines auch eine gewisse Logik hatte.
Die stimmt zwar nicht, die ist genau falsch rum, aber das war nicht einfach random.
So, also, um es jetzt abzuschließen, also, wie gesagt, ich kann das jetzt kälter machen.
Ich kann das, ich kann das, ich kann das wärmer machen.
Ich hab's meistens so auf, hier so auf 30, 30.
Die Kamera spackt jetzt ein bisschen rum bei.
Und man kann, wenn man ganz hart drauf ist, kann man auch noch hier RGB-Puffbeleuchtung machen.
Alter, sieht das kacke aus jetzt hier.
Oder, oder Sonnenlicht oder so.
Magenta.
Alter.
Ist ja abartig.
Zumindest was gut ist, worauf ich raus will bei den Lampen, ja, bei diesen Lampen.
Bevor ich da jetzt, wie gesagt, ich bekomme kein Geld dafür.
Ich wollte es euch aber halt mal zeigen.
Also, worauf ich da raus will ist, was ihr jetzt auch dran seht.
Ich stell das mal kurz wieder ein bisschen zurück.
Das machen wir und dann machen wir.
So hatte ich's, glaube ich, so irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Ich lass mal auf, vielleicht, vielleicht will ich da gleich nochmal was zeigen.
Zumindest sind das diese Lampen hier.
Und die sind meiner Meinung nach eigentlich viel zu teuer, um irgendwie massenhaft gekauft zu werden.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Lampen wirklich nicht schlecht.
Weil, und das ist das, was ihr jetzt auch gesehen habt.
Diese Dinger haben ziemlich gute Leuchtkraft, auch bei eingestellten Farben.
Weil du hast viele dieser ganzen RGB-Lampen.
Übrigens, für diesen Preis würde ich nicht kaufen.
Also, irgendwie 45 Euro oder so, wenn ich das für ausgeben müsste.
Also, gibt's auf jeden Fall.
Ich hab auch so in dem Dreh hier bezahlt.
Ist eigentlich viel zu teuer für eine Lampe.
Aber viele diese RGB-Lampen, die man so kaufen kann.
Die haben das Problem, dass sie, wenn man Farben einstellt, es übelst dunkel ist.
Also sprich, ich stell das dann auf grün und es ist halt total furzmäßig funselig.
Und das ist bei denen wirklich ganz gut.
Und wie gesagt, 45 Euro ist echt ein stattlicher Preis für eine Lampe, wohlgemerkt.
Also, da ist es gar keine Frage, dass das jetzt nichts ist, wo ich das ganze Haus mit ausstatten würde.
Die haben auch ein bisschen günstigere.
Also, das hier ist die fette Lampe, die sie haben.
Und dann haben sie noch plus.
Die gibt's übrigens auch günstiger.
Da musst du ja immer mal gucken.
Also, diese Preise hier bei Amazon sind total hängen geblieben gerade.
Also, der Unterschied zwischen der und der ist, ich zeig's euch mal beim Hersteller.
Wie gesagt, ich muss es nicht mal als Werbung kennzeichnen.
Ich krieg kein Geld für.
Genau.
Aber was ganz cool ist, die haben nämlich neben diesen normalen Lampen noch, wo ist es denn?
Es gibt die A19 oder A90 in Deutschland.
Die hat 1100 Lumen.
Steht da.
Und die haben noch eine A19 plus.
Und das ist wirklich ganz praktisch.
Die kann nämlich auch noch Infrarotlicht.
Also sprich, wenn man eine Kamera hat, die mit Nachtsichtfunktion, die aber selbst keine ordentliche Infrarot-LEDs hat.
Und meine Kameras sind halt nicht so die übelst high budget Dinger.
Ich hab ja davon welche.
Hab ich mir auch mal bei Amazon gekauft im Bundle, als es die günstig gab.
Viel, viel zu teuer.
Ich hab da 20 Euro oder so für bezahlt.
The fuck?
Warum ist das so teuer, Alter?
20 Euro das Stück hab ich dafür bezahlt, irgendwie in dem Dreh.
22, 23 Euro.
Und die haben halt nicht so die wahnsinnsgeile Infrarot-LED.
Sondern was ich jetzt gemacht hab, ist, ich hab unten im Flur das Teil, das macht ganz normal RGB-Beleuchtung im Flur.
Aber ab 22 Uhr schaltet das die Kamera, also der Home Assistant schaltet die Kamera in Nachtsicht, macht den Infrarot-Filter aus und macht die RGB-Lampe aus und macht die Infrarot-Ansicht an.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt unten den kompletten Flur bei Nacht sehen und kann der Katze beim Rumstelzen zugucken.
Hast du die auch geflasht?
Nee, hab ich nicht geflasht, aber die ist im IoT-Wlan, da passiert nichts.
Man kann übrigens auch sinnlose Sachen mit der Lampe machen, wie irgendwelche Loops und Pulsieren und sonst was, aber das mach ich nicht.
Ja, genau. Und das Ding ist wirklich nice.
Ich hab jetzt mittlerweile vier Stück.
So eine A90 hab ich, dann hab ich noch eine kleine.
Drüben, die da.
Dann noch eine, die nur Helligkeit und weiß Ton kann.
Also das ist Smart RGB-Beleuchtung, die finde ich wirklich gut gemacht.
Das wollte ich jetzt eins bloß mal sagen.
Ob der Preis jetzt irgendwie gerechtfertigt ist, 20 Euro für so eine einfache Lampe, muss man sich überlegen.
Oder 27, ist ganz schön teuer.
Also für den Preis von einer normalen, hier 5,50 Euro, kriegt man vielleicht fünf China RGB-Lampen.
So, ich muss mal kurz Chat durchgucken, dass ich nichts übersehen hab.
Das menschliche Auge nimmt Farben unterschiedlich intensiv wahr.
Ja, und vor allem sieht das menschliche Auge plus 12 FPS, das wissen wir ja alle.
Oh ja, bloß nicht.
Diese Strike-Geschichte läuft gerade voll auf dem Ruder auf Twitch.
So, hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Chat.
Rotlicht-Lampe gleich Wärmelampe.
Moment, aber ne ne, dass die Rotlicht-Lampe warm macht, ist doch nur, weil die Rotlicht eine längere Wellenlänge hat und einfach in die Haut eindringen kann.
Oder Chat?
Wo sind hier die Physik, Leute?
So, gibt's hier irgendwelche Sachen, die ich übersehen hab im Chat?
Nutzt du Text, äh, nutzt du Speech-to-Text?
Also sowas wie Deep Speech oder Minecraft?
Nö.
Leute, die öfters mal im Stream sind, die wissen's.
Ich bin kein großartiger Voice Assistant-Fan.
Das einzige Anwendungszweck, den ich sehe, was z.B. Siri oder so am iPhone hat, ist, wenn mein Auto fährt.
Der Rest finde ich immer noch per Knopfdruck oder Web-Interface oder sonst was finde ich besser.
Äh, sagt dein Chef was dagegen, so lange im Urlaub zu Stück zu nehmen?
Also, wie soll das funktionieren?
Also muss ich das ja machen.
Ist sieben Wochen nicht overkillen?
Wenn's nach mir geht, würde ich auf Twitter Trends wetten, Geld machen und nie wieder arbeiten gehen.
Ne, ist nicht overkillen.
Sieben Wochen ist top, kann ich endlich mal ein bisschen hier was machen.
Okay, ich glaube, ich hab nix übersehen.
Das ist korrekt.
True, 0W.
Wo wettest du nicht auf Twitter Trends?
Ja, weil's keine Seite gibt, wo man das machen kann.
Wie gesagt, geb es eine Seite, wo auf Twitter Trends wetten kann, wäre ich schon reich.
An Weihnachten wird Black Mesa zu Ende gestreamt.
An Weihnachten machen wir doch Kobold, dachte ich.
Ich gucke jetzt mal kurz in meine Einkaufsliste.
Genau, also was ich mir noch bestellen wollte.
Ich hab mir hier letztens diesen Switch gekauft.
Ist auch so ein China Zigbee Ding.
Hast du schon mal Outlast gezockt?
Äh, Outlast, Outlast.
Warte mal, Outlast.
Ist dieses Spiel mit der Kamera?
Es gab mal ganz früher so ein Adventure-Spiel, das ähnlich hieß, aber das glaube ich nicht, dass du das meinst, ne?
Ne, nö, ich bin kein großartiger Horror-Game-Fan.
Also, ist nicht so mein Genre.
Aber wisst ihr an welches Spiel ich gedacht habe? Ich habe an Outcast gedacht, falls das Game noch jemand kennt.
Also ich weiß, ihr werdet jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen, MonkaS war es für eine Grafik.
Aber die Grafik war für die damalige Zeit extrem poggers von der Landschaft her.
Äh, ne, das ist das Remake.
Outcast Video Game, ja hier.
Also, ähm, ich weiß für die heutige Zeit sieht das übelst kacke aus und so.
Aber überlegt euch mal, 1998 war das die mit Abstand hübscheste Landschafts-Grafik, die man je gesehen hat.
Ja, so sah das damals aus, ne?
Das war natürlich im Vergleich zu heute übelst kacke.
Aber landschaftsmäßig war das damals echt next-gen, ja.
Und es lief richtig schlecht, ich glaube die maximale Auflösung war 640 x 480 oder so.
Ähm, das einzige Horror-Game, ich weiß aber nicht, ob es als Horror-Game durchgeht, was ich gespielt habe, ist 4.
Also 4-1, 2 habe ich auch gespielt, das war aber kacke.
Und 3 habe ich mir da gar nicht mehr gegeben.
Der erste, der war wirklich poggers.
Also wer das nicht gespielt hat, sollte das unbedingt nochmal spielen.
Ähm, es sieht auch für die heutige Zeit noch ganz brauchbar aus.
Also, es geht.
Es sah für damals halt verdammt gut aus, aber das geht für die heutige Zeit.
Also es sieht immer noch ganz gut aus.
Überlegen, das ist von 2005, also da kannst du wirklich nichts sagen.
Ich soll mir eine was kaufen?
Was ist das?
Du solltest dir unbedingt eine...
Kann ich danach suchen oder ist das Toss?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt danach suche und das ist irgendwie eine...
Keine Ahnung...
Anime...
Lollipuppe oder so.
Man weiß ja nie.
Wobei der Sebaro, da können wir bestimmt sagen, wenn das hier irgendwas anstößig ist, weil der kennt ja den einen Bereich zumindest gut aus, glaube ich.
Ähm...
Alles okay, gut.
Ach so, eine Lampe, okay.
Okay, und warum soll ich mir die kaufen?
Was?
Du solltest dir unbedingt noch einer kaufen, damit es bei dir nie wieder finster bleibt.
Ist die so super hell oder was?
A Power Star.
Ganz schön dicke Kabel.
Das tut ordentlich was durch.
Was ist denn so die Lautstärke?
Lautstärke, was lab ich denn?
Leuchtstärke.
Wobei bei dem Ding weiß man nicht, vielleicht hat das auch eine Lautstärke.
Alter!
200.000 Lumen.
Wohlgemerkt, die Lampe hier.
Die, die ich hier gerade an hab, die hat 1100.
Alter, das ist ja private Sonne.
Und wo schließt man das dran an?
Ist das eine E27-Fassung oder was ist das?
Nee, E40.
Wo kriegt man denn E40-Sockel her?
Dafür hab ich noch nicht mal einen Anschluss.
Aber das ist echt brutal hell.
Was verbraucht die denn?
Wo steht denn dann was die braucht?
Oh!
Kriegt man das über?
Was sind das?
Also ich mein, mit so einer normalen Steckdose kriegt man glaube ich 230 Volt.
Maximal 16 Ampere.
Okay, reicht.
Es reicht.
Oder?
Nee, 10, oder?
16?
Nee, 16, oder?
Aus einer normalen Steckdose maximal.
Das reicht auf jeden Fall.
Aber das ist schon ordentlich.
Das ist wirklich heftig.
Die wird bestimmt auch ein bisschen warm.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ich glaub die greift man nach so einer halben Stunde nicht mehr an.
Nach einer halben Stunde hat die wahrscheinlich eh das Haus weggestrahlt.
Die braucht bestimmt einen Kühler.
Da musst du dir erstmal vom Bauer so einen flüssig Stickstoff CPU Kühler holen.
Dass du die Lampe betreiben kannst.
Dann geht das.
Keine aktive Kühlung.
Okay.
Gut, unabhängig davon.
Ich glaube das ist ein bisschen zu oversized so für meine Anwendungszwecke.
Da könnte ich wahrscheinlich hier gar nicht sitzen in dem Raum.
Die würde mich an die Wand strahlen.
Also, kommen wir mal zu der eigentlich Einkaufsgeschichte zurück.
Also davon wollte ich mir noch ein paar bestellen.
Wo kann man einstellen?
Prime?
Prime Shipping?
Gibt es da gerade keine Prime Shipping?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ich habe mal ein paar Prime Shipping gekriegt.
Anzeige ist raus.
Was soll das hier?
Kein Prime Shipping.
Die kommen aus China.
Ach nee.
Oder?
Kommen gar nicht aus China.
Ach so.
Moment doch.
Die kommen aus China.
8. bis 17.
Dezember.
Ich glaube es geht los.
0W.
Aber Free Shipping ist nicht automatisch Prime.
Ja, das geht.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was ich dafür bezahlt habe.
Weil das Ding, ich habe mir jetzt einbestellt.
Ihr wisst ja.
Konto wechseln.
Ah Mist.
Ich muss jetzt zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungen machen bei Amazon.
Moment.
Da muss ich mich erstmal bei Amazon.
Mein Passwort.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Leute, mein Amazon-Account wurde gehackt letztens.
Nein, stimmt nicht.
Das war halb.
Ich dachte er wurde gehackt.
Ich habe eine Mail gekriegt.
Unautorisiertes Login aus Irland.
Da habe ich gedacht, what?
Unautorisiertes Login aus Irland?
Was ist da los?
Und Amazon ist ja ein bisschen rückständig, was das Ganze angeht.
Du hast bei Amazon keinerlei Möglichkeit in der History zu gucken, wann von welcher IP Login war.
Was auch ziemlich fail ist.
Und dann habe ich mal ein bisschen nachgeforscht.
Dann habe ich festgestellt, Moment, Moment, Moment mal.
Sonntag 14.26 Uhr aus Irland.
Aus dem Amazon Cloud Player.
So, dann habe ich mal in die Browser History geguckt.
Dann habe ich festgestellt, der Amazon Cloud Player ist, wenn man Musik-Amazon-Playlist direkt aufmacht, ohne über Amazon zu gehen.
Dann meldet sich das als Amazon Cloud Player an.
Und um 14.26 Sonntags, da war ich gerade mit dem Stream fertig.
Vor 15 Minuten vorher.
Und habe in meine History geguckt.
Ich war das selbst.
Ich war nämlich exakt laut meiner History 14.26 Uhr auf meiner Ärzte-Playlist bei Amazon Music.
Und habe mich neu eingeloggt.
Warum das allerdings unautorisierter Zugriff aus Irland war.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute einfach mal, dass das Geo...
Wie heißt das?
Geo-Location-Rückwärts-Auflösen da von Amazon nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und meinte, meine Unity Media IP ist in Irland.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe schon ein bisschen geschluckt.
Und daraufhin habe ich mein Amazon-Passport geändert und 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung eingeschaltet.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken auf der anderen Seite, was ich bezahlt habe für.
Weil ich mein neues Amazon-Passport nicht weiß.
Das steht im Key-Pass drinnen.
Und keine Chance.
Genau, zumindest davon habe ich mir einen Switch gekauft und ich muss sagen, ich finde die wirklich sehr nice.
Ich habe mir den gekauft mit 3 Knöpfen.
Also insgesamt sind es 6 Buttons.
Also das sind jeweils ein Button.
Das ist ein Switch.
Der geht über Zigbee.
Und je nachdem, wenn man den in seine Heimautomatisierung einbindet, kann man damit die unterschiedlichen Funktionen machen.
Also der Switch unterstützt jeweils Einfachklick, Doppelklick, Dreifachklick und Taste halten.
Das heißt, man kann damit richtig schöne viele Funktionen umsetzen.
Zum Beispiel, das erste was wir einfach angenommen, ich möchte den Rollo hoch und runter machen, dort wo ich den Motor drin habe.
Könnte ich sagen, Longpress hier drauf ist Rollo runter, Longpress hier drauf ist Rollo hoch.
Aber zum Beispiel, kurzer Press da drauf ist, sagen wir, Lichtdimmen und hier ist Lichtding.
Ihr könnt es euch vorstellen, man hat damit ziemlich viele Automatisierungsmöglichkeiten.
So und auf die Frage, sind die mit Batterie oder zum Anschließen, die sind mit Batterie.
Ich bin da auch so hin und her gerissen, ob ich es gut oder schlecht finde.
Aber letztendlich mit Batterie hat den Vorteil, du musst den so runter rumfummeln.
Was die aber wirklich gut gemacht haben ist, die haben hier so eine Halterung dabei.
So man kann den einmal aus der Halterung rausnehmen und dann zur Art Fernbedienung verwenden.
Da hat man so eine Art Zigbee-Fernbedienung, wenn man das will.
Oder aber es gibt so ein magnetisches Socke, so ein magnetischer Socke.
Den kann man entweder an die Wand schrauben, an die Wand kleben oder, da sind zwei Magnete drin, zum Beispiel an den Türrahmen hängen.
Und ich habe das Ding jetzt am Eingang zum Wohnzimmer hängen, mit diesem Magnetrahmen an der Tür.
Wenn man als draufdrückt, kann man irgendwelche Aktionen auslösen.
Also aktuell verwende ich den für nichts, aber ich finde den gut.
Einziger Nachteil ist, ich zeige euch mal wie der Batteriewechsel funktioniert.
Der ist abenteuerlich.
Ja, ich glaube der hier zeigt das.
Also das Ding hat mit Abstand den schlechtesten Batteriewechsel-Workflow aller Zeiten, sonst habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ja.
Passt mal auf, man muss das hier aufmachen.
Also man muss das hier schon erstmal halb abbrechen, um Batterien zu wechseln.
Guckt euch das mal an, das ist übel.
Ey, ich breche das ab, ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich das abbreche.
Also man muss quasi den Schalter halb abbrechen, um die Batterie zu wechseln.
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Big Brain Plastiktool, was der da hat?
Guckt euch das mal, ich mache das kaputt.
So, dann muss er das abreißen davon.
So, und das war es noch nicht.
Wer jetzt denkt, da drunter ist die Batterie, der weit gefehlt, so einfach ist es noch nicht.
Das ist so ein iFixit Ding, da müsste ich das in meinem Set eigentlich auch drin haben.
So, und jetzt muss man noch aufschrauben.
Also das ist wirklich der schlechteste Batteriewechsel-Vorgang aller Zeiten.
Aufschrauben.
Geht noch weiter, geht noch weiter, das war es noch nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, so einfach ist es nicht.
Ich meine, mittlerer Schalter raus aufschrauben wäre jetzt ja auch schon, das wäre auch zu einfach.
Ehrlich, Chat, das kann nicht sein.
Jetzt muss er erst noch den Rahmen halb kaputt machen.
Wie es sich abgeht.
Also ich werde es definitiv kaputt machen, das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Ich meine, man hätte einfach einen Fach auf der Unterseite machen können.
Warum hat man nicht einfach einen Fach zum Aufmachen auf der Unterseite gemacht?
Warum baut man das so?
Ich kann mir nur zwei Sachen erklären, warum man das so baut.
Erstens ist, die Chinesen waren unfähig ordentlich zu bauen.
Gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, wenn man sich manche Sachen anguckt, die da herkommen.
An Technikgedöns.
Oh, jetzt kommen die Leute wieder.
Max, du bist ultra rassistisch.
Kannst du nicht sagen, Chinesen bauen schlechte Dinger.
Also ich habe schon so viele chinesische Dinger gekauft, die höchst fragwürdig waren.
Doch, ich kann das sagen.
Oder das zweite ist, die wollen nicht, dass man das auswechselt.
Ich tippe auf zweiteres.
Also ich tippe auf eine Kombination aus beiden.
Ich glaube, die Chinesen, die das designt haben, haben noch nicht so die Ultra-Design-Erfahrung
in solchen Dingern.
Und sie fanden es ganz gut, weil man dann wahrscheinlich einen neuen Schalter kauft
und es nicht selbst auswechselt.
Die Batterien.
Ich glaube, die halten relativ lang.
Letztendlich verbraucht es ja nur Energie, wenn man draufdrückt bei einem Schalter.
Und ein bisschen Eigenentladung.
Zigbee braucht allgemein nicht viel.
Na zumindest, er ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Er hat das Ding immer noch nicht offen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So, jetzt hat er es.
Jetzt hat er es.
Das ist wirklich witzlos.
So und da hinten ist jetzt, pass mal, jetzt muss man das noch raus machen.
Und da hinten ist die Batterie drin.
So und jetzt erklärt mir mal, welcher Big Brain Design China-Mann gedacht hat, da hinten
kann man kein Fach dran machen.
Die Batterie ist legit an der Rückseite des Gehäuses.
Das heißt, du hättest einfach eine Klappe dran machen können und schon kannst du die
Batterie austauschen.
Das ist übrigens eine gute Idee hinten ein Loch reinschneiden, finde ich sogar eine gute
Idee.
Weil man macht das Ding eh an die Wand, sieht man nicht.
Was würdest du als Wohnzimmergerät für einen dummen TV vorschlagen, wenn man keinen Google
oder Amazon oder Google-Account damit verwenden will?
Ich denke, die beste Lösung ist einfach einen PC mit Windows hinzustellen.
Ein Schild-TV, achso, achso, einen dummen TV.
Was spricht gegen einen Firestick?
Die kannst du im Zweifelsfall auch so verwenden.
Deep-Loaded-Amazon.
Hat halt den Vorteil, du musst dich um nichts großartig kümmern.
Ich persönlich bin ja Fan vom Shield-Tablet.
Ja gut, klar, Firestick muss ins W laden.
Du brauchst ja irgendeine Verbindung, dass du Sachen streamen kannst da drauf.
Nutzt du Alexa Smart Home mäßig?
Nee, ich bin kein großartiger Voice Assistant Fan.
Ja, aber guck mal, ein riesen Akt, der die Batterie zu wechseln, also das ist echt witzlos.
Mega Fail.
Ja, das machst du einmal, danach ist das Ding kaputt.
Und ich hab ja eh so ein Händchen für sowas.
Ich machs wahrscheinlich beim ersten Mal schon broken danach, wenn ich das aufgemacht hab.
Aber müsst ihr zugeben, Chat, also der Wechselvorgang ist wirklich ziemlich keck.
Triple U.
Aber ich hab Amazon zugemacht, ich wollte mir noch Schalders bestellen.
So, ich bestell mir mal nicht Apple.
Ich fände gerade auf, dass es Oppel heißt, also quasi so wie Apple nur mit O.
Warum auch immer.
Moment, die gibt's bis 16.
16 bis 19, okay.
5 Stück left, bam, easy.
11 Stück, warum hab ich 11 Sachen im...
Okay, also wenn man da Bedenken hat mit den Firesticks, was ich gut verstehen kann,
ihr kennt mich, ich bin auch jemand, der nichts gerne da mit Originalfirmen betreibt,
dann...
Genau, Nvidia Shield ist auch eine Option.
Also du brauchst kein Nvidia GPU.
Also du brauchst, wenn du zu deinem Nvidia Shield, wenn du Game Stream machen willst, okay,
aber wenn du einfach nur Android verwenden willst, sei es jetzt Netflix, YouTube,
meinetwegen auch die komischen ZDF, ARD, Media-Gedöns oder Fernseh gucken willst
über irgendwie einen Stick oder einen TV-Headend-Linux-Kiste.
Ich hab's jetzt ja selbst mit dem Shield TV.
Der Fernseh, den ich hier hab, der hat auch einen Android drauf, aber das verwende ich nicht,
weil ich verwende die Oberfläche vom Shield TV, hier, da steht's.
Das ist noch das alte Shield TV, nicht diese komische Wurst, die es jetzt gibt.
Cynigma Code hab ich auch.
Ich hab ein paar Shelley Wands, die kannst du mit dem Lichtschalter schalten.
Warum hab ich hier so viel Zeit? Ach so, das ist noch vom letzten Mal drin. Moment.
Das hab ich alles schon bestellt. Außer das, das hab ich noch nicht bestellt.
Das lass ich mal drin.
Was ist ein Shield TV? Das Ding, was ich eben gezeigt hab, hier, das da.
Das ist ein Android TV-Box von Nvidia.
Allerdings auch gleichzeitig die teuerste Android TV-Box, aber wie ich finde, die beste.
Es gibt noch ein paar Alternativen, es gibt diese RonQ-Geschichte, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das billigste ist, sich einen Firestick zu kaufen von Amazon und zu deep-loaden.
Aber kann ich verstehen, wenn man das nicht will, der wird bestimmt die ein oder anderen Sachen nach Hause schicken.
Und Cody auf einem Raspberry Pi find ich kacke.
Raspberry Pi ist für Media Sachen übelst laggy und kacke einfach nur.
Ich hab's mal probiert, konntest du komplett vergessen.
Konntest du komplett knicken, das war so eklig.
Hehehe, der M-Core.
Also ein Shield TV ist, find ich, das beste.
Das aktuelle Shield TV sieht leider ein bisschen fail aus.
Das ist jetzt, das Shield Pro sieht jetzt so aus, wie das, was ich hab.
Und das normale Shield TV ist so ein komischer Zigarettenanzünder.
Weiß nicht so genau, was Nvidia dabei gedacht hat, bei diesem Design.
Das kannst du doch nicht mal ordentlich hinlegen, irgendwie.
Und Fernseh gucken mach ich halt auch nicht über Shield TV direkt.
Ich hab noch ne Single Board Computer Box, die steht daneben.
So eine hier, steht daneben.
Mit ner Festplatte drin, das ist so fix und fertig, da kann man ne Festplatte anschließen.
Da hab ich nen Lidungs drauf installiert.
Und hier am USB-Port hängt ein Dual-Tuner.
Wind-TV-Dual-Tuner-Stick. Über den kann man Fernseh gucken und Fernseh aufnehmen.
Und hier hab ich, auf dem Shield TV hab ich noch Kodi drauf.
Und da streamt dann hier die Aufnahmen von dem Ding. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ja selbst über Shield Tablet wollte ich das Ganze nicht machen.
Da ist es schwierig, TV-Sticks zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Und dann brauchst du dann auch nen Backend, das die Aufnahmen macht.
Und ne Festplatte an Shield TV und sonst was.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm machste lieber noch ne billige zweite Kiste hin.
Ist auch mal ganz gut.
Weil wenn dann das Shield TV mal verrecken sollte, ist nicht alles weg.
Oder zumindest nicht alles erstmal benutzbar.
Die Kombi läuft jetzt schon seit 2 Jahren oder 3 Jahren.
Ohne Probleme.
Eher 2 Jahre, wir haben es ja im Stream zusammen installiert damals.
Äh Matt wie ich, du musst mich da gar nicht überzeugen.
Ich glaub das dir sofort, dass der Amazon Stick Sachen nach Hause schickt. Sofort.
Das wird mich eher wundern, wenn der Amazon Stick keine Sachen nach Hause schickt.
Äh schon gesehen die Steckdosen, was? Ernsthaft? Wirklich?
Schon gesehen die Steckdosen die du umgeflasht, das hättest du nicht öffnen brauchen.
Gib für den Raspberry Pi ein Tool, das das Motor OTA flasht.
Echt?
Also sicher.
Also ich mein du meinst wahrscheinlich Tuya Convert.
Aber Tuya Convert geht nicht mit den Steckdosen die ich hab.
Du meinst das hier, ne?
Der Eichler ist am Start. 15 Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Excellent.
15 Monate, das ist ja schon richtig.
Was macht denn dieser Pikmin Typ hier?
Das ist der Pikmin Typ, oder?
Das sieht original aus wie der Pikmin Mensch.
Ja also wer hat's eben im Chat geschrieben?
Der Ares. Ich geh mal davon aus du meinst das hier, ne?
Also wenn du das hier meinst, das ging mit den Steckdosen nicht.
Gibt's ja eigentlich Battlefield 3 manchmal zu sehen, ja?
Tatsächlich, ab und zu mal schon.
Das geht mit den Steckdosen nicht.
Amazon lügt, also sprich das was bei Amazon zu den Steckdosen steht, dass es damit geht, ist alte Firmware.
Es sei denn du hast noch was aktuelleres gefunden, was das kann.
Da wär ich natürlich dann sehr daran interessiert zu wissen was es ist.
Apropos Speicher. Google Photos ist wohl bald nicht mehr... Was?
Kennst du noch alternativ am besten Unlimited Cloud Speicher?
Also Unlimited Cloud Speicher kenn ich nix.
Aber wenn das so hart auf hart kommt, dass wir das Archiv irgendwo anders archivieren müssen,
dann gucken wir mal was irgendwo so ne Storage Box kostet.
Wird auch nicht die Welt sein.
Was kosten gerade bei der Hetzner Server Auktion Speicherplatz?
Zeig mal her.
Wie viel brauchen wir in Sebaro?
Oh nein, ist zu teuer.
0W
Im Zweifelsfall kaufen wir irgendwie 5 Euro Google Drive oder so.
Cheap. Ich hab mal richtig billige Storage Server gefunden.
Die waren aber so richtig fail mit Natta 4 und sowas.
Cheap Storage. VPS.
Was gibt's denn da so?
Time VPS for you. Oh klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend. Alles klar.
Design for Big Data Storage. Okay. Ehrlich.
Wow.
MonkaS
Bisschen teuer vielleicht.
Da müssen wir mal schauen, was da möglichst günstig ist.
Aber Sebaro sagt, wenn's geht, bisschen früher Bescheid, dass wir uns was überlegen können.
Du kannst ja mal gucken, wie groß das Archiv aktuell ist.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter. Also ich guck mal in meine Einkaufsliste.
Also Door Sensors, äh, nicht Door Sensors. Schalter haben wir.
Das, äh, mit der Lampe hatte ich euch gezeigt. Ach ja, übrigens.
Ich hab euch ja grad.
Ich hab euch ja grad diese Lampe gezeigt, die noch die neben RGB LED auch Infrarot kann für das Nachtsichtgerät.
Und was, was sich jetzt mal wieder gelohnt hat, ist, ich hab ja meine Kamera auch mit Custom, mit Custom Firmware geflasht, nämlich mit der hier.
Guck mal, ob ich euch eine Kamera zeigen kann, was die für Möglichkeiten hat.
Das ist nämlich richtig nice. Da kannst du eine 20 Dollar Cam, äh, richtig featuremäßig richtig aufbohren.
Muss mal gucken, dass ich euch die aus dem Keller zeige, weil da kann ich nichts leaken.
Nein, das ist die, äh, das ist nicht die aus dem Keller.
Das ist die aus dem Keller. Excellent.
Genau, ähm, das ist die Custom Firma, die ich auf meiner Kamera drauf hab.
Und das hat halt den riesen Vorteil, dass man wieder mal keine Hersteller-Cloud braucht, keine Hersteller-App braucht.
Und dass man auch, äh, über die AP ziemlich viele Funktionen fernsteuern kann.
Zum Beispiel Infrarot-Filter an-aus, Infrarot-LED an-aus, Nachtsichtmodus an-aus und sowas.
Zeig euch mal, was man da alles einstellen kann. Wohlgemerkt, wir reden hier von einer 25 Dollar Kamera.
Das ist jetzt die, die ich im Keller hängen hab.
Da kann ich es euch am besten zeigen, weil, äh, stört euch mal nicht, dass da Kamera-3D-Printer dransteht.
Das ist kein 3D-Printer, wie ihr vielleicht seht, ja.
Natürlich ist es Route 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, was sonst.
Also, was ihr alles Mögliche einstellen kannst.
Äh, kannst einstellen, ähm, ganze Video-Geschichten kannst du einstellen, was du haben willst.
Äh, Nachtsichtmodus, sonst was.
Äh, Infrarot-LED, Infrarot-Filter, automatische Nachterkennung.
Die LEDs kann man vorne aus, die Motion Detection ist übelst kacke, die würd ich da gar nicht, äh, anschalten.
Das Ding hat einen RTSP-Stream, einen MJPEG-Stream, kann über MQTT-Status versenden, Status empfangen.
Sound abspielen, kann, äh, Mails und Telegram-Nachrichten schicken, wenn es Bewegung erkannt hat und sowas.
Also, das hat wirklich richtig viele nice Features.
Ach so, ja, hin und her schwenken kann man die Kamera auch übers Web-Interface.
Das hat richtig LED-Configuration, was auch immer, ach genau.
Das hat richtig coole Features, die man sonst im Leben nicht bei, ähm, äh, 25 Euro Kamera findet, ja.
Das ist schon nicht schlecht.
Äh, und wie gesagt, das ist jetzt, man macht das ja über RTSP-Stream und nicht über diese komische, über dieses komische Webfrontend hier.
Max, bist du es?
Kommt drauf an.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich's bin.
Vielleicht bin ich's.
Es wäre möglich, es ist im Bereich des Möglichen, dass ich's bin.
Ähm, ja, die Motion Detection ist wirklich nicht so schlecht, ja.
Also, das packt das Ding nicht.
Das ist total ausgelastet dabei.
Das schafft vielleicht ein Bild pro Sekunde, wenn's hochkommt.
Da ist unsere selbstprogrammierte Motion Detection viel besser.
Wie heißt die Cam?
Also, das hab ich auf einer Wyze Cam Pahn laufen.
Aber du musst gucken, dass du die jetzt nicht aktuell kaufst, weil aktuell sind die viel zu teuer.
Viel, viel zu teuer.
Ich hab 25 Dollar bezahlt damals für 25 Dollar.
So, hier, guck mal, bei Wish.
Ich hab die 25 Dollar, ich hab mir einen...
Kein Fünferpack, ich glaub, drei Stück davon und drei Stück von den anderen hab ich mir bei Amazon.com bestellt.
Da hab ich zwar insgesamt, glaub, 20 Dollar noch mal für Versand und Import bezahlt.
Aber insgesamt war das viel günstiger.
Also, das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht, ja.
Ja, Wild Alfred, schön, dass du den Weg hergefunden hast.
Nice.
Viel zu teuer, was ist mit denen los?
Das Ding ist niemals 80 Euro wert.
Das ist eine total billige Schrott-Cam.
Das einzig Gute daran war, dass sie schwenkbar ist, Custom-Firmware-Support hat.
Also, naja, Support.
Es gibt eine Custom-Firmware dafür.
Ist ja nicht so, dass es offiziell supported wäre.
Und dass sie billig ist.
Für 80 Euro gibt's viel bessere Kameras.
17 Euro ist okay.
Sind die noch bei Sinnen?
Warum soll ich da, warum soll ich 70 Euro?
Kosten die beim Offiz...
Ja, okay, ja, Leute.
Warum, warum ist das bei Amazon.com so teuer?
Hä?
Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt noch mal angucken.
37 Dollar, okay.
Chips to Germany.
Wird das noch mal extra berechnet?
Add to Cart.
Checkout.
Ach nee, da kommt noch...
Warum ist das so teuer?
Was ist denn mit Amazon?
Ich meine, im offiziellen Shop kostet 29 Euro.
Warum soll ich bei Amazon 8, 9 Euro mehr dafür bezahlen?
Einfach, weil es Amazon ist oder wie?
Shippen die nach Germany?
Kann man...
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Die Gedanken habe ich mir nämlich auch gemacht.
Kann man nicht ein x-beliebiger 1080p USB Webcam
für 15 Euro von Amazon hernehmen
und an einen Raspberry Pi anschließen?
Doch, du kannst eine USB Webcam an einen Raspberry Pi anschließen.
Du kannst aber auch einfach die jeweilige Raspberry Pi Kamera kaufen.
Der Nachteil daran ist, du kannst es nicht drehen.
Also du kannst nicht pan, pan tilt machen.
Du kannst es nicht drehen und neigen.
Du kannst den Raspberry Pi nicht in ein gescheites Gehäuse
mit einer Kamera packen zusammen.
Wasserdicht ist das...
Okay, wasserdicht ist die hier auch nicht.
Wasserabweis ist das Ganze schon mal gar nicht.
Und die Kombination Raspberry Pi Kamera und Infrarot LED Nachtsicht
ist auch nicht so einfach.
Also das bessere Paket ist tatsächlich, finde ich,
so eine 30 Euro Billigcam mit Customfirmware.
Aber nicht...
Also die haben mir total arsch offen 30 Euro bei Amazon.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ne, 70 Euro bei Amazon, ich glaube, es geht los.
30 Dollar ist genau das, was ich dachte, ja,
das ist die oberste Grenze, vergiss es.
So, lass mal gucken.
Shipping, zählt das schon nach Germany?
Okay, sagen wir mal, ich bestell fünf.
Und dann checken wir out nach Germany.
Kann man das irgendwie berechnen lassen?
Ah, fuck.
Die Shippen, die Shippen nur nach Kokona.
Warum macht man denn so was?
Das ist zu viel Freedom für mich.
Ja, dann bleibt einem doch nichts anderes übrig.
Mit Amazon ist es günstiger, wenn man viel bestellt,
was Import angeht.
Ja, ja, weiter.
Und was steht jetzt, was das Import kostet?
Der steht nur da, wenn ich mich einlogge, ne?
Na, super.
Weil wenn das hier, und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass es nicht pro Kamera zählt, weil sonst hätte es
sich damals nicht gelohnt, wo ich es bestellt habe.
Weil wenn das hier wirklich pro Kamera ist,
dann lohnt sich das natürlich absolut nicht.
Ich glaube, ich bin mir sicher, dass das hier
nicht pro Kamera zählt, weil sonst hätte es
sich damals nicht gelohnt, wo ich es bestellt habe.
Das lohnt sich absolut nicht.
So wird halt auch mal schnell aus der 29 Dollar Webcam
oder aus der 29 Dollar Kamera, Chinacam,
wird halt auch mal schnell ein 60-Euro-Teil.
Das ist halt Fail.
Das Gute ist, wenn man so Sachen über Amazon bestellt,
mit diesem Amazon-Import, das Gute ist, dass das nicht
beim Zoll hängen bleibt.
Wenn du was aus den USA bestellst, du kannst
eigentlich nicht drauf verlassen, dass der Kram
beim Zoll liegen bleibt.
Die Ami-Hersteller sind nicht in der Lage,
diese Zollsachen richtig zu deklarieren.
Ich musste jedes Mal, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei
euch ist, Chat, ob ihr das öfters mal gemacht habt
oder auch schon da schlechte Erfahrungen mit
gehört habt, ich musste jedes Mal, wenn ich aus den
USA was bestellt habe zum Zoll, jedes Mal,
die kriegen das einfach nicht hin.
Die Chinesen machen das besser.
Die haben einfach was drauf, was nicht stimmt.
Und schon geht das einfach durch den Zoll durch.
AliExpress verschickt das dann über Rotterdam,
über die Niederlande mit PostNL nach Deutschland
und schreibt bei 300 Euro Elektronikartikel drauf
12 Euro Elektroteile. Easy.
Die Chinesen kennen da halt nix.
Im Zweifelsfall bist du ja auch nicht der
Arschte, sondern der chinesische Hersteller.
Du willst das ja nicht, dass da irgendwie
Sachen falsch deklariert sind.
Wie gesagt, ich weise das alles von mir.
Das würde ich nie im Leben gutheißen.
Was Gerüchte über Geiselnahme bei Ubisoft?
What the fuck? Was? Ernsthaft?
Was?
Bo, ich sehe da nix.
Chet, she baited mich.
Ja, also das, also man kann sich zwar über die
Ubisoft Spiele auskriegen, aber dass die, also
das muss ja wirklich nicht sein.
Was denn das für eine Seite?
Ja, das ist von eben.
Was ist das für eine Seite? Hab ich ja nie gehört.
Canadian News. Ach stimmt, die sind ja hier.
Das ist ja Baguette. Vergesse ich immer wieder
bei Ubisoft.
WTF? Was ist da los?
Was ist da los?
Dutzende Leute werden als Geisel gehalten bei
Ubisoft in Montreal.
Polizei ist am Start.
Krasser Scheiß, was ist da los?
The fuck?
Gtf? Ubisoft
Fuck was ist da los? Die meisten sind zum Glück beim Homeoffice
Ist Ubisoft nicht Rainbow Six? Ne ich mach jetzt keinen blöden Spruch
Nein das muss ich mir jetzt verkleifen Aber ich hoffe wirklich, dass das alles
knifflig ausgeht Krasser Scheiß App, guck was da rauskommt
Definitiv nicht Poggers Ja hoffentlich sind nicht so viele da, die
meisten dürften ja wirklich Homeoffice machen Aber gespannt was da rauskommt
Vielleicht ist es ja auch nicht so schlimm wie es auf den ersten Blick aussieht
Vielleicht gab es ja auch nur irgendwie, frag mich nicht, irgendwie falsche Bombenalarm
oder irgendwie sowas Keine Ahnung mal gucken
Also ich hoffe ja nicht, dass denen irgendwas passiert
Das finde ich auch immer teilweise bescheuert Es gibt ja Leute auf Twitter, gerade auf
Twitter, Twitter ist sowas das Social Media Sachen angeht, das ist das allerschlimmste
in dieser Richtung Die machen sich jetzt da drüber lustig
so nach dem Motto, ach guck mal hier, Assassin's Creed hat gesackt jetzt, die haben es sich
anders verdient blablabla Also nur weil einer ein scheiß Game macht,
wünsche ich ihm nicht, dass er bei irgendein Geizelnamen erschossen wird oder so
Also die haben teilweise ein bisschen Dachschaden Social Media Leute
Na ja also ich hoffe, dass das alles gut ausgeht
Ja schauen wir mal was rauskommt Okay, machen wir mal weiter, wo sind wir stehengeblieben
Bei euch gibt es doch manchmal, ja siehst du in meinen Vorschlägen, habe ich das sogar
laufen hier Ich weiß ja, dass bei euch ein paar Elektronikleute
am Start sind Ist sowas erlaubt, dass man E27 Lampen auf
E14 Sockel macht Weil die Adapter, das sind alles irgendwelche
China Adapter Es gibt ja so ein paar Adapter, die rein
irregularienmäßig nicht funktionieren Zum Beispiel, was man nicht machen kann ist
eine Steckdose mit diesem kleinen Eurostecker Ich weiß nicht, ob das Ding wirklich Eurostecker
heißt, ihr wisst was ich meine Diesen kleinen zweipolischen Stecker
Auf mehrere kleine zweipolige Stecker Die Sachen gibt es zwar von China Herstellern
Aber das geht eigentlich nicht Diese kleinen Dinger
Was?
GU10?
Das könnte tatsächlich, ne GU10 ist die Also was man nicht machen kann spezifikationsmäßig
Was halt auch nicht zertifiziert Wenn man sowas hier hat, von diesem Stecker
auf eine Steckdose mit mehreren dieser Steckern Das ist nicht erlaubt
So und die Chinesen bauen das trotzdem Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, vielleicht
ist das bei E27 auf E14 auch so, dass man das eigentlich gar nicht verwenden sollte
Ich meine, es gibt Adapter zu kaufen bei Amazon, aber das heißt nichts, weil das sind China
Hersteller Das ist mit Sicherheit auch ein China Hersteller
Wobei das ist, ne das ist E14 auf Stimmt überhaupt nicht
E27, das ist umgedreht Das ist, achso ja gut, je nachdem von welcher
Seite du guckst passt das Kannst du noch mal ein Video über Dubstep
erinnern Ja gut, das war auch die Zeit wo es überall
in jedem Video gemacht hat Wupp wupp wupp wupp
Berührungsschutz, ahja In wie weit?
Du meinst, weil das da nicht richtig reingeht Also sprich, weil man dann hier irgendwie
an das Metall dran kommen könnte Hier so in die Ritze
Weil die Lampe nicht richtig reingeht Ja, weil sowas brauche ich
Oder zumindest wäre es nicht schlecht zu haben Gucken ob sie da verschauen
Wieso brauchst du es, ja weil die meisten WLAN Lampen die halbwegs was taugen, die sind
E27 und ich hab aber im Fluor 4 E16 E14 Socke Am Leuchtmittelwechsel könntest du an Metall
kommen Ja gut, da mach ich eh den Schalter aus
vorher Aber ich versteh schon was du meinst, das ist
auf jeden Fall keine schöne Bauweise dann Ja gut, ähm
Gibt es eigentlich, was mir gerade einfällt Gibt es ein iPad USB Adapter für USB Sticks
oder so?
So was gibt es ja wirklich Weil
Ich hab mir schon öfters überlegt ob man nicht irgendwie USB Sticks an ein iPad dran
bekommt Ob sowas was taugt?
Ist denn das Audio, USB C, SD, Micro SD und USB
Das was taugt, ich glaub ja netter Weil das wäre ganz praktisch, wenn man, könnte
ich jetzt als Weihnachtsgeschenk gebrauchen Was werden bei Lightning nicht unterstützt
Aber das ist doch Lightning hier Das glaub ich nicht, dass die Produkte anbieten
die keine Funktion haben, so komplett nicht Ja das geht seit längerer Zeit aber nur
unbedingt Inwieweit?
Weil sowas wäre als Weihnachtsgeschenk für meine Mutter nicht verkehrt
Die macht ja quasi fast alles mit ihrem iPad Die macht auch ihr Steuerzeug, kopiert die
sich da übers iPad Was halt nervig ist, weil die hat so einen
Backup USB Stick in so einem uralten 1 Gigabyte Frag mich nicht, frag mich auch nicht warum
Aber es ist schwierig das ihr dann auszureden, dass ihr ihr Steuerkram kopieren könnte übers
iPad Zum Beispiel kannst du keine Apps auf die SD
kopieren Ah ne das ist egal, das ist wurscht
Bis dann, machs gut sehbaro Ja doch sowas, sowas ist glaube ich echt
nicht schlecht Guck mal du hast, du hast 2x USB
Die SD Karten braucht kein Mensch Ich glaube sowas bestell ich mach das ganz
gut als Weihnachtsgeschenk ist jetzt so teuer Gut ist
Äh wenn du jetzt Moment was?
Wenn du jetzt einen Laptop für deine Arbeit kaufen müsstest
Was würdest du dir holen? Irgendwelche bevorzugten Marken oder Specks?
Ja so 6000 Euro iPad Pro, iMac Pro, nee, warum hast du die Dinger?
Nee wünsch mir nicht holen Quatsch Ähm, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, weil
ich mich schon ewig nicht mehr mit Laptops beschäftigt haben
Auf der Arbeit aktuell haben wir Thinkpads Genau, von Lenovo sind die ja mittlerweile
Die sind mit Docking Station auch echt gut Also die haben stabile Scharniere am Display
das ist das erste worauf ich immer gucke Du hast mit der Docking Station massig Anschlüsse
ein bisschen knapp mit den Anschlüsse nur am Notebook
Nur am Notebook hast du glaube ich maximal 2 USB
Ja was Thinkpad einmal Carbon zeigt man ja Oh was ist das?
Es sieht schon mal aus wie ein ganz traditionelles Thinkpad
Ja mit diesem komischen Nippel in der Mitte Das ist ja so ein IPL, so ein Thinkpad
Es ist ja in Lenovo mittlerweile Markenzeichen dieser komische Huppel
Trackpoint
Ok ob das jetzt, sind glaube ich Metall an der Scharniere
Was hat man für Anschlüsse USB
Strom und 2x USB
Nee das ist USB USB, HDMI
Was ist das?
Ist das ein USB-C oder ist das da Stromanschluss Wir kennen das nicht genau
USB-C Thunderbolt ja
Tja muss ja Thunderbolt sein Weil das USB Forum die USB 4 Speck so
verkackt hatte Da muss der Intel noch mal kommen und sagen
wir machen das USB aber richtig
Preis scheint sich auch halbwegs in Grenzen zu halten
Ja aber ich kann dir leider nichts raten Ich hab mich null mit Notebooks beschäftigt
und ich hab es in nächster Zeit auch nicht vor mich mit Notebooks da großartig zu beschäftigen
sodass ich dir was sagen könnte Habe ich keinen Bedarf gerade aktuell dran
Was Lenovo ist schwierig zu bekommen wegen dem Rechtsstreit mit Nokia
Was haben die denn schon wieder für komische Stonks Anwaltdinger da untereinander zu klären
Über was streiten die sich denn gerade
Lawsuit
Was Lenovo hat verkauft Ok guck mal was der heise schreibt zu
Patentstreit mit Nokia Lenovo stoppt Verkauf in Deutschland
Oh
Kekwade
Lenovo fehlt Lizenz zur Nutzung des Videokodas
Ah Lizenzscheiße alter Wie mir diese ganze Patent- und Lizenzierungsgeschichte mega sowas
von auf den Sack geht Merke ich jetzt hier einfach mal wieder dran
Die Welt könnte deutlich einfacher sein ohne diesen Scheiß
Und ich sag nicht, dass Leute die sich was ausdenken kein Geld damit verdienen sollen
oder so Aber das ist unnötig kompliziert und kacke
einfach nur
Guckt euch diesen Wirrwarr um Strikes auf Twitch jetzt an
Ich mein klar es soll nicht so sein, dass jetzt irgendwelche Künstler am Hungerbrot
da irgendwie am Hungertuch nageln müssen Und auf Twitch gucken sich alle kostenlos
ihr Zeug an so ist das ja nicht gedacht Aber da wird ja teilweise vom rechte Verwerter
die abgetretenen Rechte verwertet von dem Ur-Enkel des Rechteverwerters seiner Mutter
So also das ist echter Wahnsinn was da läuft
Und am Ende kommt ja noch nicht bei dem was an großartig das erstellt hat
Übrigens wisst ihr was ich mich schon seit einer Weile frage
Warum darf man eigentlich, das ist jetzt eine wirklich ernst gemeinte Frage
Warum darf man nicht öffentlich rechtliches Fernsehprogramm frei verwenden
Ich mein die Frage wirklich ernst Weil ich mein die Dinge heißen nicht umsonst
öffentlich rechtlich Und jeder von uns bezahlt Gebühren dafür
Ich mein mir ist klar warum das rechtlich problematisch ist
zig Leute haben irgendwelche Urheberrechtsansprüche und die Typen wollen das nicht rausrücken
Aber rein vom, wie soll man das jetzt nennen, vom Ansichten her
Warum ist das eigentlich nicht besser geregelt Ich mein warum ist öffentlich rechtlicher
Fernsehprogramm nicht zur freien Verwertung freigegeben
Ja ich mein jetzt nicht wenn die lizenzierten Filme ausstrahlen
Ich mein die öffentlich rechtlichen Produktionen
Also sprich warum kann ich nicht oder warum darf ich nicht das verwenden für beispielsweise
irgendwie YouTube Videos die sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen
Ja ich weiß dass das urheberrechtlich geschützt ist
Aber es gibt regelmäßig Klagen von Sendern
Gegenüber Organisationen, Einzelpersonen, Firmen was auch immer
Die Beiträge verwendet haben von ihnen um sich mit dem Inhalt auseinanderzusetzen
Also zum Beispiel man nimmt einen 40 Sekunden Ausschnitt von einer Talkshow wo der Pfeiffer
sich mal wieder über Killerspiele auslässt und berichtet darüber was
Also sprich man zeigt das Video und labert dann drüber
Warum kann man sowas überhaupt irgendwie ein öffentlich rechtlicher Sender was machen
Ich finde es liegt doch schon im Namen drinnen wenn das ein öffentlich rechtlicher Sender
ist den wir alle bezahlen warum kann man den Content nicht frei verfügbar machen
Das leuchtet mir nicht ein
Wie gesagt ich weiß dass das rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen aktuell eben hergeben dass es nicht frei ist
aber warum warum nicht
Genau also das leuchtet mir nicht ein
Ja gut über kommerzielle Nutzung kann man sich jetzt natürlich streiten
Es ist ja dann wieder was anderes aber die sind da teilweise echt giftig was das angeht
Ich bin gerade so in den Kopf gefragt warum ist das überhaupt so dass ich das bezahlen
muss aber nicht verwenden darf oder warum müssen wir das bezahlen und wir dürfen das nicht
verwenden oder verwerten für andere Sachen
Das beste ist immer noch dass die öffentlichen Reaktion Content wechseln ja genau so was
meine ich warum ich mein guck mal jeder von uns bezahlt den Kram mehr oder weniger
Warum darf ich nicht in Reaktion drauf machen auf irgendwie nen Beitrag sagen wir aus was
gibt's denn also wieso oder so mal angenommen mal angenommen es gibt mal wieder irgend so
einen komischen Beitrag bei wieso wo irgendwelche weiß ich wir testen die besten Cloud Anbieter
warum darf ich nicht den Beitrag zeigen und drauf reacten um mich darüber auszulassen
was die für ein Mist erzählen warum das ist doch eigentlich auch im öffentlichen Interesse
irgendwie dann die Regelung was diese öffentlich rechtliche Rundfunk angeht die kann ich jetzt
zum größten Teil nicht nachvollziehen ist aber komplett komplett eigenes Thema wieder
ich bin da auch so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde
also diese diese diese dieser Zwang dass alles und jeder unabhängig davon ob was benutzt
oder irgendwie sonst was das bezahlen muss finde ich prinzipiell schlecht
es gibt leute die gucken das oft die konsumieren das und die haben damit überhaupt kein Problem
das sich da zu Gemüde zu führen wenn ich dann sehe dass in solchen Zeiten wie jetzt
wo die Leute teilweise Probleme haben der Rundfunkbeitrag angehoben wird oder zumindest
vor hatten den Rundfunkbeitrag anzuheben wenn du siehst dass dort alleinerziehende Mütter
müsst ihr euch mal müsst ihr mal google gucken in wie nennt man das beugehaft genommen werden
oder werden sollen und ich glaube wurden schon weil sie den Rundfunkbeitrag nicht bezahlt
haben also dann läuft wirklich irgendwas aus dem Ruder
also ist nicht das ist nicht normal ja dazu kommt und das ist eigentlich der größte
Kritikpunkt den ich an diesem öffentlich rechtlichen Zwangsabgaben Ding habe dass mir der Content
nicht gefällt der Content gefällt mir zum größten Teil nicht weil ich den Eindruck
habe dass gerade dort wo es drauf ankommt nämlich sei es jetzt irgendwelche Berichterstattung
zu aktuellen Ereignissen dass das wirklich alles andere als neutral passiert ich habe
mir zum Beispiel als in den USA gewählt wurde ein bisschen morgens habe ich im Bett gelegen
habe ich ein bisschen im Smartphone rumgeguckt ja da waren sie ja alle on von ARD war on
bis spiegel bis die bild waren waren alle on so und ich habe mal ein bisschen geguckt
bei was war das glaube ich ob das war bei der bild habe ich eingeschaltet mal bei was
war das spiegel tv oder so und und auch mal bei der ARD oder Tagesschau und ganz im Ernst
die man kann man kann von den Kandidaten halten was man will also es soll auch ruhig jeder
wählen was er will weil er vielleicht konnte einer von euch damit wählen aber ich habe
den ARD stream aufgemacht und das erste was ich gehört habe war sinngemäß wo sie erzählt
haben wie dumm ein Großteil der Amis ist jetzt nicht wortwörtlich aber sinngemäß und das
wollten die auch so sagen wie dumm ein Großteil der Amis ist weil sie ja Trump gewählt haben
und die ARD weiß es mal wieder besser ist das neutrale Berichterstattung unabhängig
davon ob ich das jetzt mein kandidat ist oder nicht aber gerade als öffentlich rechtlicher
sender solltest du die sache doch möglichst objektiv und neutral berichten ich meine die
bild hat das besser gemacht und der bild also wem draußen das eher zu der sendung von
ARD oder der bild ich habe danach den bild stream angemacht und da hatten die irgendwelche
typen dort in washington sitzen von der einen seite von der anderen seite haben sich darüber
unterhalten was dann so in den letzten jahren fehl gefällt wurde und sonst was also die
fucking bild war viel neutrale als das in der ARD ich meine das war jetzt so eine moments
nach ich habe das nicht lange geguckt ich habe das eine viertel stunde oder so vielleicht
geguckt bei meinen aber trotzdem mir ist bei der ARD direkt von anfang an so so diese diese
belehrungssache wir erklären euch jetzt wie das ganze auszugehen hat und wer unserer
meinung nach der richtige ist so ist sofort so mitgeschwungen und die anderen die haben
da einfach nur normal darüber geredet was mir persönlich viel besser gefällt und gerade
die aufgaben aus meiner sicht von öffentlich rechtlichen sender werden doch eben du kannst
ausschnitte zeigen klar du musst aber damit rechnen dass das dann der also es gibt mit
sicherheit ein gesetz was das abdeckt ja es gibt ja auch genug entscheidungen für wenn
du was zeigst oder drüber drüber drüber redest also drüber labers und ich mit dem
thema beschäftigt dann ist das erlaubt was sich aber nicht da war was aber die fernsehanstalt
nicht davon abhält dich einfach mal zu streiken uns anzu anzuzeigen ist es ja nicht also
quasi und die unter jessas abmahnung zu schicken wurde dann mit denen vor gericht landest was
übrigens lustigerweise wir auch mit bezahlen das ja auch so ein ding was irgendwie schon
unter aller sau ist also sprich wenn du also ich sag jetzt einfach mal du ihr wir bezahlen
den beitrag wenn wir dann damit sagen wir mal ein reaction video machen was denen nicht
gefällt dann verklagen so und wir müssen quasi bezahlen dass jungs also ich bezahle
die klage gegen mich quasi ja habe ich letztens ein belicht in bericht drüber gesehen dass
irgendein radios sender irgendein radios sender hat ne youtube redaktion sage ich jetzt weiß
ich nicht wie man es nennen mag channel verklagt weil die einen auszug von einem beitrag von
den verwendet haben was sie nicht gut von ein bisschen darüber hergezogen haben und
die sind jetzt es ist quasi in einem ich weiß nicht ob es richtig zusammen geht irgendwie
in ein hamburger fernsehsender gewesen und irgendwas komplett am anderen ende die haben
sich jetzt eine berliner edel anwaltskanzlei genommen um sie vor gericht zu vertreten was
wir quasi auch mit bezahlen weil es ja öffentlich rechtliche gebühren sind exzellent war ganz
exz extrem exzellent ja gut ich mein kannst das geld natürlich auch ausgeben weil du
musst ja nicht selbst verdienen und dazu kommt auch eine sache die mir beim öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunkgeschichten bisschen auf den kicks geht vieles der gebühren oder großteil der
gebühren die man bezahlt werden ja nicht etwa für content den man sehen will oder nicht
sehen will also nicht für inhalte content verwendet sondern zum beispiel um die renten
zu bezahlen der ard leute und ztf leute also da ist auch ein hoher anteil altersvorsorge
drin also sprich selbst wenn die nichts machen die müssen quasi den rundfunkbeitrag erhöhen
dass sie die rinde bezahlen können über kurz oder lang also das system ist nicht so
optimal finde ich verbesserungswürdig oder wie man so schön sagt business dort gibt
es noch sachen nachzuschärfen auch so ein schöner umschreibung von das ist scheiße
nachschärfen
schau dir diverses stil von charme supporter demos an überdenkt noch mal da ist kaum einer
dabei gewesen der nicht einer ist doch egal das doch das doch vollkommen egal das können
beides meinetwegen die größten folgen aller zeiten sein aber es kann nicht sein dass
dir die ard oder den sender quasi mit jedem satz unterschwellig mitteilen möchte was
die korrekte ansicht ist du kannst dir die meinung ja selber bilden guck dir die demos
an und sagt die sind alle bescheuert das gut dass sich mit dem thema beschäftigt aber es
soll dir keiner vorkauen was da was jetzt die deine weltansicht sein soll das ist da sind
die meiner meiner überhaupt nicht für da machen es aber genauso auch so ein ding ich
habe einen auszug gesehen wo sie berichtet haben über diese nicht die letzte korona
demo die die vorletzte korona demo da wo irgendwelche leute die treppe vom reichstag
hoch gerannt sind und sowas ja habe ich gesehen bei der ard und das wurde so dargestellt als
waren das irgendwie frag mich wie viel waren es denn 40.000 oder so 40.000 entweder verrückte
oder nazis wo ich war aber alter wie großartig und differenzierter kannst du das ja nur wirklich
nicht machen das sind mit sicherheit viele idioten dabei ja da sind dann vielleicht so
irgendwelche kerle noch da am start wie hier wieder vegane koch oder oder savian neidu
der ja sagt es gibt nicht mal viren oder sowas da sind mit sicherheit leute dabei die richtig
dachschaden haben aber du kannst dich nicht pauschal hinstellen beide bei übrigens die
bezahlen die gebühren da auch für kann sich nicht hinstellen und solche und solche sachen
da die leuten mit auf den weg geben die das gucken das sind mit sicherlich mit sicherheit
auch genug leute dabei die einfach nur wahnsinnig unzufrieden sind mit der aktuellen situation
weder leuten dass es korona gibt weder leuten dass es viren gibt weder nazis sind noch reichsbürger
sind noch sonst was so einfach nur leute die die aktuelle situation aus unterschiedlichen
gründen scheiße finden oder kannst du dich nicht hinstellen und so tun als sind das alles
irgendwelche verrückte und nazis das wird der situation einfach nicht gerecht das ist
so ein ding das erwarte ich nicht von der ard dass man das macht leider ist es so ja
das sollte nicht so sein das das stimmt also es es gab sau viel korona berichterstattung
aber das ist ja das ist ja gerade in der aktuellen ist ja auch ok entweder
also das korona news finde ich ok ob man da jetzt jeden tag irgendwie großartig brennpunkte
und updates zu braucht wage ich auch mal zu bezweifeln weil ich meine im prinzip ändert
sich ja da nicht täglich irgendwas dran das ist ja weder heute auf einmal da und morgen
auf einmal weg
ich folge auf twitter gar keine weil auf twitter sind zum größten teil nur leute
die mir auf den sack gehen aber was mich halt einfach nur wundert ist warum kriegt das
die bild sogar besser hin das ist ja eigentlich das was mich schockiert hat dabei die bild
von der bild erwarte ich das nun wirklich nicht von der bild hätte ich erwartet dass
die übelst pro der einen seite pro der anderen seite berichten ja nicht dass du trotz ist
egal ob man es gut oder schlecht wenn bezahlen muss man es eh also drum rum kommt man da nicht
ja gut so wo sind wir stehen geblieben was haben an 21 20 so spät so ich wollte noch
gucken was ich hier noch ach du scheiße das ist ja noch ich ich hab erst drei zeilen
oder so von meiner einkaufsliste runter ja genau was ich mir auch noch bestellen wollte
was übrigens exzellente ex exzellentes equipment ist ich wollte mir nämlich noch ein paar
shellys mit powermeter bestellen die da was du zahlst seit um seit umzug keine rundfrunk
mir das natürlich auch gut da haben sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht gecheckt so genau was man was an
den dingern wirklich gut ist also außer dass sie so groß sind wie zwei oreo kekse aufeinander
das ich versuche mal ob die irgendwo anschlussplan haben das sind relays die ich übers wlan
schalten kann und jetzt mal wieder von der aktuellen diskussion hier weg zu hören das
sind relays die ich übers wlan schalten kann und zwar mit firmware die keine cloud braucht
obwohl das shelly cloud heißt ich sagte es ja jedes mal das total hängen geblieben
dass man shelly.cloud als domain hat und eines der hauptsächlichen verkaufgründe ist dass
man es nicht über die cloud verwendet also wirklich massive big brain idee also ich muss
in den shop sind da anschlusspläne genau weil ich habe ein paar also zum beispiel jetzt
eine sache die ich gerade im kopf habe warum ich mir zumindest mal ein bestellen will und
ihr wisst ja ich bestelle immer mindestens drei wenn ich wenn ich sowas bestelle unten
im flur haben wir eine steckdose da wird immer einen staubsauger dran geladen so eine akku
akku staubsauger und das problem ist dass der beim aufladen also normalerweise sollte er
wenn er aufgeladen ist geht die led aus und gut ist und das netzteil wird auch ein bisschen warm was
dabei ist so und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht es wäre erstens cool wenn ich das ausschalten
könnte wenn ich sie über nacht lade abends aus dem bett weil ich nicht will dass das netzteil
vielleicht doch mal anfängt zu fackeln ich könnte einfach ein anderes netzteil kaufen aber was viel
cooler ist dadurch dass die quasi gucken was das ganze zeug verbraucht was da dran hängt kann ich
daraus mir ableiten ob der staubsauger voll geladen ist oder nicht wenn lustig wie du
gefühlt jeden stream die cellis zeigt ja die dinger sind auch poggers also sprich ich kann
dann einfach überwachen wie viel das ladegerät so verbraucht oder beziehungsweise wieder wie viel
der wie viel watters gerade lädt das staubsauger und wenn akkus geladen werden das ist ja immer
so eine kurve also sprich das geht dann geht dann erstmal volle pulle los mit so und so viel und
dann geht es am ende wieder runter also sprich die letzten 20 prozent von so einem akku lädst du
ja nicht genauso volle pulle wie die erste wie die ersten zwei drittel von dem akku das machst du
dann immer ein bisschen bisschen weniger und deswegen ich habe das hat mir das mal angeguckt
wenn der so weiß es jetzt aus dem kopf gar nicht mehr ich glaube unter unter vier watt
verbrauch fällt dann ist er eigentlich voll man würde ja eigentlich davon ausgehen er geht aus
aber es könnte auch sein dass er aus ist und irgendwelche standby dinger einfach nur so viel
brauchen er würde mir würde einfach ausgehen der schaltet das einfach ab die dass die lade schaltung
am akku macht dann einfach dicht vielleicht ist einfach nur die vier watt die versuche ich die
wärme vom netzteil und die led oder was auch immer keine ahnung zumindest wenn das unter vier watt
verbrauch hat habe ich schon nachgeguckt dann ist das staubsauger voll und deswegen wollte ich mir
so ein ding unten an die steckdose basteln hinter die steckdose basteln da kann man einmal vom tablet
an und ausschalten und ich bekomme mit meiner staubsauger voll ist was eigentlich ziemlich
leise anwendung ist was ist was zu deiner info wurde gestern ein querdenken anhänger und auch
ein anmelder einer demo festgenommen der auf facebook eine video gepostet hat dass er heute
am freitag in die schule gehen wird was die kinder zu ach du scheiße gibt schon genug leute mit
dachschaden metzger von beruf okay da würde ich mir jetzt gedanken machen kommt mit küchenbeil
oder wie wahnsinn ja wie gesagt ich will nicht bestreiten dass es da total bescheuerte leute
gibt ja ist mit sicherheit so aber davon auszugehen dass es bei 40.000 leute nur bescheuerte sein
müssen das ist ein bisschen zu einfach
so genau davon bestelle ich mir mal drei stück und wo wir gerade dabei sind warum ist der auf der
seite so teuer der 1 pm das einschnec gute frage bei amazon ist der billiger oder 22 ja wtf warum
ist er so teuer weg
warum kriege ich den bei amazon für 20 und im offiziellen shop für 37
einer kostet 37 dass ich ach so okay das habe ich verkackt okay gut der kostet
kostet weniger alles klar ich habe nichts gesagt wie weit bist du mit deinem rtsp links also ich
habe heute eingebaut dass der theoretisch die streams aufnehmen kann wenn man knopf drückt
warum diese form passt der unter putz ja das problem ist eigentlich also noch mal was zu
diesem diesem kamera aufnehmen projekt zu sagen hier also wer wissen will vor was ich meine ich
habe es ja sogar mal nach einem stream auf github hochgeladen das ist übrigens faked mit den 95
prozent javascript das sind eher 80 prozent z sharp der rest javascript das sind 95 prozent
javascript weil ich hier komplette komplettes komplettes vue js eingecheckt hat ganz vergessen
genau was wollte ich jetzt sagen bei dem projekt ja ich tue mir immer schwer motiviert zu bleiben
wenn ich so wenn ich so ein projekt mal drei vier fünf wochen hin zieht und man nicht so
richtig vorwärts kommt das ist auch ein bisschen was komplizierteres und das problem was ich auch
noch habe ist ich bin halt kein wirklich guter javascript frontend design mensch ja also ich
krieg da was halbwegs ansehnliches hin aber ich tue mir da teilweise schon echt schwer mit
und ich bin ja aktuell so am gucken ob ich nicht vielleicht dann noch den ein oder anderen dafür
gewinnen kann der da mitmacht weil zu zweit und das habe ich gesehen wo ich da mit meinem
kollege mal diese diesen ruten planer programmiert habt zusammen ja wir mal ich habe mit dem
arbeitskollege zusammen den ruten planer programmiert wo man sich wo sich handwerker
quasi ihre termine reinklicken können und der berechene dann die optimale route von kunde zu
kunde und man kann auch zeit slots eintragen sprich man muss um 12 uhr 30 bei dem sein und
1430 bei dem und das berücksichtigt er dann das hat viel mehr spaß gemacht mal viel motivierender
weil wir das zu zweit gemacht haben da kam auch was viel besseres raus wenn ich da alleine am
start bin da verliere ich immer so ein bisschen die lust vielleicht ich weiß nicht vielleicht
kennt ihr das also mir geht es immer so wenn ich am anfang bin ich übelst motiviert und denkt mir
22.000 sachen aus was man alles noch geiles einbauen könnte und ich habe so die fehler
den ich dann immer mache ich verliere mich da oftmals in detail implementierung also ich ich
bin dann zwei stunden am überlegen ob ich jetzt was weiß ich da einen public property auf die
klasse draufmache oder doch lieber ein event mache oder ob ich nicht vielleicht doch lieber reactive
extensions noch mit reinnehmen soll oder ob ich die datenbankpflicht vielleicht nicht lieber über
craft ql machen soll oder sonst was da habe ich zwei stunden lang überlegt habe zwar einiges
neue gelernt aber im prinzip nix geschafft ok ich sehe der chat kennt das ich glaube das ist
relativ normal nach gpc ist jetzt wäre es noch mal übertrieben also gpc machen wir tatsächlich
kenni gpc machen wir und zwar gpc machen wir für die object detection soll ich euch das book ich
zeige euch das jetzt mal kurz für alle die beim letzten stream nicht dabei waren ich starte das
jetzt mal dass ihr wisst wovon ich rede einmal progas an dann zeige ich euch den letzten stand den
wir auch im stream hatten so und wir haben nämlich was programmiert wo man webcams oder
nicht nicht webcams security cameras empfangen kann und was das für ein desktop ist der beste
desktop das ist supreme big brain desktop so und wo man webcams streams empfangen kann
jetzt kann mal kurz gucken was wir machen müssen wo ist ffmpeg oh oh nee mein rider läuft ab geht
sofort watch run so oh da steht noch da steht noch das iphone drin lull ja moment das muss
raus da steht noch das iphone drin ne ne das iphone brauchen wir nicht wir brauchen hier den
den stream noch mal hier mal rein so jetzt kann ich euch zeigen was das macht aber mal chrome auf
lokal haus 5000 was ja was warum was hier los
die objekt detection läuft nicht objekt detection läuft nicht jetzt aber
fünf zahle fünf zuschauen ja das ist normal immer sobald man jedenfalls so was in der rechnung
ist jetzt immer vorbei so dafür steigt jetzt wieder wenn ich zeige was im browser rauskommt
am ende genau also wir haben nämlich die webanwendung programmiert die kamera bilder
empfängt also ich habe so ein video so den youtube video runtergeladen von einem typ der
irgendwelche gymnastik übung macht und ihr seht der macht objekt detection also sprich der
erkennt dass das eine person ist und wo die sich im bild befindet was eigentlich schon ziemlich
nice ist da und das alles jetzt mich mit allzu großer mit allzu großem rechen auffahren ich
mein guckt euch das mal an das ding braucht macht es hier mal groß das ding braucht gerade
vier prozent cpu last ok du objekt erkennung ist nicht mit dabei die objekt erkennung braucht
auch noch ein bisschen was aber es ist es ist nicht so viel ja also es ist lass es mal 15 10 10 15
prozent also sprich das läuft auch auf einem raspberry pi halbwegs somit somit 1 2 bilder
die sekunde aber das reicht ja voll und ganz genau ist das übrigens ein cell phone falls er
nicht wusste ja aber das ding ist auch trainiert auf person deswegen funktioniert das ganz gut
und das ist das was wir letzten im stream programmiert haben und das ist das wovor ich
gerade gesprochen habe mit dass ich bei solchen projekten immer übelst unmotiviert bin wenn ich
da alleine dran am basteln bin stimmt wir hatten wir hatten doch noch das video mit dem fitness mit
dem fitness grill moment war plupp das fitness grill ist das das fitness grill
das das fitness grill genau das waren wir jetzt mal an weil man sieht auch in bewegung dass
er das ziemlich gut erkennt muss das video erstmal anlaufen klar also das simuliert jetzt
webcams er erkennt eine bank der erkennt eine person und das alles relativ echtzeit so ungefähr
mit sagen wir mal so zwei sekunden da nimmt jeden keyframe da nimmt jeden keyframe und schiebt das
durch diese object detection das heißt er erkennt ihr halt auch dass die person hin und her wackelt
ja die macht jetzt gleich irgendwelche liege stützen oder so auf der bank oder sieht mir auch
jetzt sagt das geht nach vorne wir haben uns extra von youtube fitness videos runtergeladen um das
auszuprobieren weil in fitness videos bewegen sich in der regel die leute guck mal da erkennt
sogar dass die hoch und runter auf der bank geht excellent übrigens die object detection
ist ganz schön am rödeln gerade genau und das ist das was wir letzten streben gebastelt haben
worum es mir eben ging bei dem was hier was ich hier gezeigt habe ja und da habe ich halt immer
das problem dass ich mich und der chat ja auch dass ich mich bei solchen projektnehmer vom
hundertsten ins tausendste am basteln bin anstatt mich auf irgendwas zu konzentrieren also was ich
heute gemacht habe ist ich habe eingebaut dass man die sachen aufnehmen kann von den webcams
also sprich mal einen aufnahme button und sprich man kann aufnahme auflösen durch object detection
durch manuelles klicken auf den button oder durch den timer das habe ich heute eingebaut aber ich
bin da also wenn man damit mehrere leuten dran programmiert ist deutlich motivierender als wenn
man dann nur alleine bastelt wie viel gigabyte ram hast du gute frage ich glaube 32 g 32 g aber
man braucht da nicht viel ram für du brauchst glaube ich zum trainieren relativ viel ram
wie zur helle funktioniert so eine erkennung gut wie das im detail funktioniert kann ich dir nicht
sagen weil ich nehme ein fertiges fertige ich sag mal library ist nicht wirklich ein library ich
nehme was was das ist nicht jolo nein das ist nicht jolo das ist tensor flow light mit irgendwelchem
fortrainierten set mit frag mich nicht ganz vielen personen dass der gut personen erkennt
das ist nicht jolo jolo habe ich mir auch überlegt ob ich jolo nehmen soll also jolo ist auch eine
objekte detection du hast du only look once heißt das glaube ich in dem fall aber jolo
ist unbenutzbar langsam auf dem raspberry pi jolo ist genauer ups das wollte ich gerade aufmachen
jolo ist genauer als diese tensor flow geschichte die ich hier verwende aber es ist halt schneller
und ganz ehrlich wenn es da um alle zwei sekunden an den keyframe zu erkennen geht ist genauigkeit
jetzt nicht so extrem wichtig es ist allemal besser als motion erkennung von den normalen
von den meisten anderen kameras jolo worum geht es gerade um um das hier echtzeit objekterkennung
in bildern jolo neun mona dankeschön für den sub excellent subscription
wäre damit sicher auch eine fahrzeugerkennung möglich oder ja gibt's auch gibt's auch gibt's
genug beispielprojekte wo das leute umgesetzt haben aber wenn man so was machen möchte wie
fahrzeugerkennung oder leute in der fußgängerzone dann kann man das nicht mit dem raspberry pi und
diesem projekt machen was ich gemacht habe das kann man mit diesem projekt vielleicht machen dann
braucht man aber ein hardware beschleuniger am besten ist eine ordentliche rechner mit grafikkarte
dann kann man auch jolo über gpu machen dass es hat bessere erkennung und geht mit der gpu flitzt
schneller also wenn man da wirklich sachen machen will wie in echtzeit autos straßenverkehr
analysieren oder fußgängerzone analysieren das geht aber dann braucht man doch eine ganze ecke
bessere hardware was aber dann auch kein problem haben sollte sein sollte weil wenn man solche
anwendungszwecke hat dann kann man da ja auch die passende hardware für verwenden genauso davon
wollte ich mir drei stück bestellen 37 euro passt poggers.next
so wo war ich denn jetzt stehen geblieben außer dass es gleich 21.45 ist
kennst du den lebenslauf von dem jolo typ keine ahnung was ich mir mal wieder bestellen wollte
hier excellent ich hatte letztens mal was ist das für den preis mittlerweile sind die noch
ganz dicht ich gebe doch keine acht euro für die für 300 gramm aus was aber ist irgendwie
alles was ich was ich gerne gerne bestelle und und esse irgendwie in den letzten zwei
monaten dreimal teurer geworden acht euro für 300 gramm china kohl kimchi gibt es auch
im supermarkt ja aber schmeckt nicht jedes also das schmeckt mir am besten das ist sogar das
einzige das einzige vegane produkt was ich kaufe wobei man auch hot hot kimchi hot kaufen kann
aber was ist mit ihnen los alter 57 pro dose für 57 pro dose kriegst du wahrscheinlich schon
nicht erdöl oder oder ja gold nicht aber andere sachen als kimchi letztendlich ist das eingelegter
china kohl was rechtfertigt dass das 7,50 kostet die anderen sachen bewegen sich in besseren
regionen außer das da vielleicht aber ist das so teuer das andere zeug tf weil überlegt das
noch andere andere viele mögen was überlegt ob das noch andere du meinst ob das vielleicht
noch so viele andere mögen dass es gerade knapp ist oder so aber das ist es ist ein
eingelegter china kohl den kaufe ich nicht für acht euro 7,50 also so was hier in dieser
richtung gibt es gibt es glaube ich auch beim edeka und so was schmeckt kacke das schmeckt
also ich habe mal beim edeka so eine kleine dose kimchi gekauft und das hat das hat im
prinzip geschmeckt wie gewürzgurken china kohl also so ist so wie als hätte man china
kohl in gewürzgurken zeug eingelegt richtig kacke aber das hier ist nice das ist richtig
gut das ist das ist scharf hot ist gehe ich mal von aus hot hatte ich noch nicht ich habe
bisher tatsächlich das ist das einzige vegane was ich was ich je bestellt habe hot ist wahrscheinlich
ordentlich hot weil das ist auch das hat auch schon eine gewisse schärfe aber hot ist wahrscheinlich
richtig power das schmeckt richtig gut wenn man so saures zeug mag also das ist ziemlich
ziemlich sauer was ist bisher im wahrenkorb ja heute war man so nicht ähnlich allzu viel
eine sd karte den kartenleser fürs ipad und ein paar sich b schalter ich wurde heute ein
wenig ein wenig sei tracked zwischendurch ja bisschen öfters genau ja gut aber ich
wollte mir eine dose kimchi kaufen was ist hier los warum warum warum geht das heute
nicht weil ich gebe keine 57 aus kannst du knicken er muss aber halt auch sagen was ich
gerade gemeint habe das ist einzig vegan was ich kauf man kann kimchi bestimmt auch super vegan
machen das ist im endeffekt china kohl chili paste und das halt stehen lassen luftig verpackt stehen
lassen mit mit zusatzdingern ja gut manche machen dann wahrscheinlich doch irgendwie
ein bisschen fisch zeugs mit rein oder so das ist wahrscheinlich dann die nicht vegane variante
aber so viel geld habe ich nicht aus vergesst so viel geld kann ich dann aus so da wollte ich
bei der gelegenheit gerade noch mal gucken ob es meine sich b thermostate ein bisschen günstiger
gibt und vielleicht auch in einem in einem bei einem shop wo ich was bestellen kann da gibt's
mal die wollen ja sagen wir alles was ich kaufe irgendwie wirklich jetzt zwei monate später teurer
ich habe das auch noch für frag mich nicht 25 euro oder so gekauft was ist da los
war pearl bestelle ich nichts aus prinzip den laden mag ich nicht da sieht aus wie ein schlechter
shop von 1995 ich habe da noch nie was bestellt ich werde da auch nichts bestellen ich kann euch
gar nicht genau sagen warum aber dieser shop gegen den habe ich irgendwie ultra abneigung
vielleicht versteht jemand wahrscheinlich nicht ich kann es nicht genau erklären aber die optik
schreckt mich unglaublich ab ich will da nichts bestellen finde ich auch das sieht aus wie eine
schlechte wie eine schlechte webseite von 1998 ganz so schlimm aber in die richtung auf jeden fall
sich die ist ein war ein wireless protokoll für iot geräte sieht aus wie teleshopping genau
wahrscheinlich finde ich das wenigstens schlecht weil es aussieht wie teleshopping ich habe ich
habe diese tele ich habe das gehasst früher im fernsehen die teleshopping dinger oh mein gott oh mein gott bob es
ist so toll was man damit alles machen kann und jetzt gibt es sogar zwei für den preis von
mein gott ist das toll ne ne das war das kann ich mir nicht angucken das war ganz grausam
ab heute entdeckt dass man bei nordsee infinite gratis backfisch brötchen bekommen kann warum
geben die einem gratis brötchen so viel man will genau also sich wie ist nun wählen wir
lassen nicht wählen wohlgemerkt kein wifi aber ein drahtloses protokoll für zum beispiel
heimautomatisierungsgeräte der vorteil davon ist es braucht weniger strom als wählen also
sich die geräte oder sie werden geräte halten in der regel batterie mäßig viel länger als
wählen geräte der name ist vielleicht ein bisschen doof aber es gibt so zwei sachen es gibt sich
bier und es gibt sie wave nimmt sich alles nix rein von technischer sicht ist beides ok funktioniert
beides gut sie wave hat eigentlich den großen vorteil dass die geräte per per standart untereinander
kompatibel sind was erst mal gut klingt problem ist aber sie war geräte sind meistens eine ecke
teurer und bei sich bie sind viele große hersteller dabei die damit mischen die zwar
nicht wirklich darauf achten großartig kompatibel zu sein aber es gibt mittlerweile genug tritt an
peter software die ziemlich viele geräte ansprechen kann das heißt so der so der große vorteil von
sie ist eigentlich auch weg und ich sehe dass ich sehe so dass sie gerade gewinnt was iot
protokolle angeht und ich meine nicht gegen wählen ja gegen wählen stinkt nix an wählen
ist das einzige was es ja so in nächster zeit geben wird in der richtung und wählen tut ja auch
gut was fünf fischpunkte gleich bad moment was moment 50 fischpunkte gleich gratis backfisch
registrieren mit email gibt ihr moment 10 minute mail incoming ane nordsee fischpunkte kundenclub
prämien das da meinst du das dort das probieren wir jetzt aus das probieren wir jetzt aus never
donate and never stop neighbors wifi free entertainment das probieren wir jetzt aus
wo kann man sich dann melden sammeln bei jedem deiner nase an der app alte können
die das nicht mal ordentlich machen warum muss ich das über die scheiß no apps warum warum
nicht einfach über den rechner im browser muss das wirklich immer so eine für alles
in der eigenen app installieren ich meine wenn ich in den laden gehe wenn ich in den laden
gehe und dort mein qr code einscannen dann ist es ja ok dass ich das mit einer app machen muss
aber muss ich das wirklich von anfang an in der app machen und kann es nicht immer browser
machen es promo für die app ja das hast du recht ja und wie ist das so also hier max
riss wie ist das so kann man damit 10 minute melden sich registrieren weil dann installiere
ich mir einfach die app auf einem android tablet oder auf irgendeinem ausgemustern android tablet
generieren ein paar codes weil die qr code den brauche ich ja dann wahrscheinlich nicht in der
app ach so doch du brauchst den kirk in der nordsee das probiere ich das muss ich mir
aufschreiben dass das probiere ich aus dann gehe ich ich gehe morgen zur nordsee ich
gehe morgen ich fahre morgen zur nordsee und hole mir fünf brötchen das funktioniert
einfach nur zu wissen ob es funktioniert excellent excellent hat es wieder gelohnt
zu streben heute so sind wir morgen nordsee die nordsee gebaten um was es geht es geht
um kostenlose brötchen bei der nordsee ok nordsee clubapp ist mir doch egal ob die clubapp
schlechte bewertungen hat ich will kostenlose brötchen haben was interessiert mich auf
was die bewertungen die app hat was haben die sich eigentlich dabei gedacht dass da dass
man ganz rechts an den bildschirm muss um die um die bilder durch zu scrollen wer hat
sich das bei welcher usability experte bei google hat sich das eigentlich ausgedacht
nordsee clubpunkte was morsels nein nord wo steht dann da was es da für punkte gibt
mobile first ja
jetzt der rote gibt es bestimmt auch für windows naja das werde ich aber auf jeden
fall morgen ausprobieren kostenlose nordsee brötchen excellent chat exquisite was hältst
du von der ps5 ich halte weder von ps5 noch von der xbox serious x aktuell irgendwas weil
ich keine ahnung davon habe ich habe mich damit nur das nötigste mich darüber informiert
ich habe mir zwar das video angeguckt wo der eine japaner gesagt hat dass die playstation
5 eine hat aber ich kenne mich nicht damit aus ich weiß jetzt aus dem stegreifen auch
nicht mal genau was dann auf was er jetzt für cpus drin waren außer dass es irgendwelche
amd ddinger sind ich glaube acht kerne oder 12 8 top 8 und ssd ist hamse kann ich nichts
zu sagen das nächste was ich machen werde ist in dieser richtung wenn denn dann mal
wieder rtx 80 90 lieferbar sind so wie jetzt excellent und wenn reisen 5900 lieferbar sind
so anscheinend wie jetzt
allmax ist es ist poggers dass das funktioniert ah guck mal hier gibt es die prämien wundern
die sich nicht wenn ich damit 5 qr codes bei der nordsee anrücke wundern die sich da nicht
irgendwie ok was gibt es denn für 30 fischpunkte gibt es ein 02 cola für 40 gibt es ein prima
für 50 gibt es ein backfisch backfisch da gibt es ja mehrere sachen für 50 ok ok also
dann probiere ich das mal morgen aus ich nehme dass es nicht so auffällig ist nehme ich
einfach mal fünf tablets mit wenn das klappt also an tablets und smartphones mangels ja
nicht ich pack dann einfach mal fünf tablets morgen bei der nordsee aus also was könnte
man da schönes zusammenstellen einmal pompfried einmal backfisch spagett und einmal was zu
trinken dabei ist eigentlich ganz gut oder braucht man drei braucht man drei dreimal
ab da haben doch bestimmt in ihren agb sowas drinne stehen dass man es nur einmal einlösen
kann probesuch oder irgendwas in der richtung kaputt wenn das klappt wo haben wir noch irgendwie
nordsee wo ist denn da wo haben wir noch nordsee hier einmal pro gerät das ist kein problem
ich nehme ja ich nehme ja fragt mich nicht fünf tablets mit ich habe genug an geräten
mangels nicht und danach schmeiß ich die ab runter und registriere mich neu ok wo haben
man in hanau nordsee nordsee hanau was nur da
was ist denn das hanau im ach da ist der saturn ok ach jetzt weiß ich wo das ist genau hier
hier steht der hier steht dieser joint da ist so ein da ist so ein komische fragt mich
so irgendwie so ein denkmal drauf sieht aus wie ein joint das ist also die frage ist also
die eigentliche frage ist lohnt es sich nur um nordsee quasi um was kostet das um drei
euro zu zubaten lohnt es sich dort für in die stadt zu fahren fünf tablets mitzuschleppen
oder drei drei tablets reichen auch in korona zeiten und dort sich pomfret ein backfisch
spaghetti und cola zu holen klingt solide finde ich ich meine geräte mangels nicht das
ist so eine runde wandern da werde ich das nicht machen das rate auf dem raspberry ok
wir gucken jetzt fangen sie nicht auf alle videos zu gucken ist ja fast 22 uhr das ist
auch massive big brain hier kollege hat eine eigene app geschrieben die die burger king
api anspricht die gutscheincodes laufen niemals ab und man kann da fast alles die es jemals
gab abfragen und die klappen auch und wie löst man die gutscheincodes ein in der app
oder wie geht das ich habe die burger king app noch nie noch nie verwendet ja dann muss
ich da morgen zur nordsee du hast fest du hast korrekt festgestellt ja so sieht es
aus an der kaffe also wenn das nicht gegen irgendwelche agbs verstößt oder ist es den
verkäufern vollkommen egal so stimmt wie sieht es eigentlich bei ubisoft aus irgendwas
neues twitter wir gucken wir gucken twitter polizei polizei einsatz in twitter twitter
bei sowas bei sowas ist twitter tatsächlich nicht verkehrt latest
ich trau mich immer nicht twitter bei solchen sachen durch zu scrollen weil da posten manche
ja auch mal irgendwelche abartigen sachen zwischendurch ok dann war es vielleicht doch
irgendeine drohung mit irgendeinem sprengsatz oder so sank fack alles klar mal schauen was
da rauskommt bin echt gespannt und ich hoffe nicht dass ihnen irgendwas passiert
ja die sache ist nur da wo ich morgen wandern gehe ist komplett andere richtung als da wo
die nordsee ist ach qr code das heißt was macht man dann wenn qr code screenshotten
und dort vorzeigen oder wie ist das moment github muss jetzt gucken dass das gibt's bestimmt
auch auf github schon burger king api wobei ich gar nicht wobei ich burger king überhaupt
nicht mehr mag ich war jahre nicht mehr bei mcdonalds oder burger king burger king api
burger king makes you fat api a rapper around burger king unofficial burger king api klar
willst du abwarten wie sich amd mit den grafikkarten schlägt ehrlich gesagt nicht ich will jetzt
ehrlich gesagt eigentlich mal endlich einen neuen rechner kaufen aha aha ist das so 3080
ti kommt demnächst haben die nicht erzählt diesmal wird es keine 3080 ti geben alter envidia
jebait da wird es wieder zig resit das videos geben auf youtube wo sich die leute über
envidia lustig machen da gibt es ja jetzt schon tausende von guckt euch das mal tausende
gibt es davon
beste ich lese ich lese mir gar nicht mehr die texte durch ich finde ich finde es einfach
nur schon lustig wenn ich überhaupt nur es reicht wenn ich mir einfach sehe ich könnte
ich könnte fast schon mitsprechen obwohl ich kein wort spanisch kann oder sowas kommt
jetzt gleich ich habe keine ahnung was er sagt ich habe kein plasma also doch ich weiß
ich kenne die original story aber sie das ist das der typ das ist ein spanischer komiker
der sie irgendwas mit resit das nennt
ich könnte den scheiß den ganzen tag angucken also wenn du schlecht drauf bist wenn du schlecht
drauf bist einfach es gibt es gibt zwei sachen die man machen kann
es gibt zwei es gibt zwei sachen die man machen kann wenn man schlecht drauf ist einmal
man guckt sich fünf fünf resita memes in folge an egal ob was es geht einfach zuhören
das ist gut da ist man danach meistens schon besser drauf oder wenn man wenn man was anderes
braucht wenn das nicht reißt wenn es das wenn es das nicht reißt dann hört man sich einmal
an hört man sich einmal den hier an
danach bist du besser drauf
also kann es gibt glaube ich keiner der danach nicht besser drauf ist wer das gehört hat
die mca das ist spielmusik das passt schon
ich glaube nicht dass es da für den toss gibt dass 2007 auf youtube
hat denn gesehen habt seht ihr das chat ja habt ihr es gesehen wer da wer da hier da
ist er wo ist man passendes emote ich kann dieses
emote nie verwenden ich muss es jetzt wo ist es wo habe ich es hier da ist er ich habe
ihn gespottet der originale gaben war das da
und was auch noch übertrieben nice ist
was ich auch noch hören kann wenn gar nichts man hilft und man schlecht drauf ist das ist
ein stunden carbie gourmet race
genau also man schlecht drauf ist das best was man kann so jetzt mal um auf die frage
einzugehen von ja aber wahrscheinlich nicht vom portalsong oder von game musik um jetzt
mal kurz noch mal auf die frage einzugehen von tactical stg ich weiß die frage ist vielleicht
gerade unpassend jedoch wollte ich dich mal fragen ob du noch bettel vieler war spielt
also bettel field die letzten zwei bettel fields habe ich nicht großartig gespielt ich hoffe
ja immer noch drauf dass mal wieder ein ordentliches bettel field kommt so und overwatch kann ich
mir auch nicht mehr geben also overwatch hatte von anfang an probleme in einigen disziplinen
die sie bis heute nicht auf die reihe gekriegt haben zum beispiel das 2cp von anfang an absolut
kack spielmodus war was blizzard nicht interessiert sondern weitere maps in dieser richtung gebaut
hat und die noch schlechter waren als die original maps und sie haben sie haben sie
haben an wirklich allen stellen irgendwie gefällt bei overwatch ja sie haben mit ihrer
komischen overwatch league was aufgebaut was total einseitig von blizzard abhängt und
es dementsprechend keinerlei tier 3 tier 2 anderen tournaments oder irgendwas gibt was
man auch nur ansatzweise aktive e-sports szene nennen kann das was auch der grund ist dass
im prinzip die einzigen nachwuchs spieler für die owl halt irgendwo aus korea kommen
bis auf ein paar ausnahmen aber es gibt ja keine großartige nachwuchs szene und auch
keine also guck mal wenn heute jemand sagt ich möchte e-sports profi werden was sagen
die dann leute was meint ihr was sagen leute die sagen wir mal jetzt irgendwie 17 18 sind
und sagen sie sie wollen keine karriere in e-sport machen was spielen die für ein spiel
dass ich mir alles gefällt also ich lasse mir gefallen wenn einer sagt lol ja fortnite
meinetwegen ich meine dann vielleicht nicht die knallharte e-sports nummer die hatten
mal diese die hatten mal dieses world tournament aber danach kam glaube ich nichts mehr aber
zumindest mit fortnite content und gedönst kann man als wenn man pro gamer so definiert
als jemand der mit spielen sein lebensunterhalt verdient dann kann man auch durchaus fortnite
nehmen dann muss es halt gamer plus video content oder so sein ja passt leucht leuchtet
alles ein lol fortnite 5 garantiert nicht cs lol valorant vielleicht ja ich wundere mich
auch immer wie viele leute wie viele leute also pubg in korea vielleicht ja eventuell
dota würde ich sagen noch starcraft außerhalb von korea nicht eventuell meinetwegen auch
noch fifa vielleicht auch noch hartstone oder sowas meinetwegen lasse ich mir auch
noch gefallen aber niemand niemand sagt overwatch und das ist das worauf ich raus will keiner
sagt overwatch was man an den zuschauer sahlen sieht was man an dem generellen der gelben
berichterstattung sieht was man daran merkt wie zurückgefahrene content ist was man an
dem ganzen game einfach anmerkt und blizzard hat es an so vielen stellen verkackt ich war
übelster overwatch fan und ich fand das spiel am anfang so sowas von geil und ich hab mir
gedacht hey die müssten bloß noch an den richtigen schrauben ein bisschen drehen zum
beispiel dass in den observer modus so ein spectator modus und so ein replay modus und
sowas dass das jahre gebraucht hat bei overwatch bis das gekommen ist war schon mal der witz
und solche geschichten also ich dachte mir von anfang die müssen an ein paar sachen
drehen aber was haben sie gemacht sie haben ihre schwächen weiter ausgebaut sowas wie
2 cp maps oder ihre patches einmal im halben jahr die nicht bedacht gepatcht haben sondern
eine sache an ich komplett useless gemacht und dafür eine andere sache op so dass ich
jetzt erinnern das kann nicht sein dass die leute sechs monate das gleiche spiel also
machen wir einfach das was die leute jetzt spielen useless und dann machen wir was anderes
und dann spielen die leute das wenn man das so macht da muss man das alle paar wochen
machen mittlerweile geht schneller weiß ich hat nicht auch amazon ihren overwatch konkurrenten
eingestellt warte mal was war denn noch mal dieses jaja ich weiß nee amazon hat gesagt
sie fangen wieder von vorne an zu entwickeln aber das spiel war auch mega beschissen das
habe ich mal bei seagull oder so im stream gesehen das hat ich hatte so keinen bock dieses
overwatch dieses amazon overwatch zu spielen nicht palladins nee nee nee nee das wenn
ihr den titel hört werdet ihr feststellen das habt ihr gar nicht gehört wie ist das
denn crucible crucible crucible genau crucible das meine ich genau das crucible ich weiß
gar nicht ob es überhaupt noch irgendwo drin steht ist offiziell kanzelt ok ich dachte
die haben es also es ist ja noch gar nicht lang her wo die es gekänzt haben verstehe
lustig ja uns wie gesagt also blizzard hat das hat hat nicht die stärken von auf war
zumindest ist das meine ansicht da es gibt bestimmt andere leute anders hin die haben
nicht ihre stärken ausgebaut in overwatch die haben nicht die sachen angepasst wo ich
wo zumindest ich gesagt hat ok der hätte man die hätte man ausbauen oder oder verbessern
müssen dass das spiel richtig gut wird sie haben eher noch die sachen die nicht so gut
waren an overwatch ausgeweitet zum beispiel dass auch ziemlich viele helden gekommen sind
die absolut keine mechanics hatten ich mein was haben die sich gedacht bei brigitte am
anfang einen hell zu machen denn ein no-aim melees dann hat wie kommt man auf so eine idee
macht man das quasi wer hätte man so so was in richtung high-skill gameplay so was wie
tracer genji oder so eingebaut der dann als ultimaten dann macht ok meinetwegen ja aber
du kannst doch nicht so ein mele ich halte ich halte er einen maus button gedrückt und
das gegen den gegner ist gestand einbauen also also ich kann euch ehrlich gesagt nicht
ich kann ich kann nicht logisch nachvollziehbar irgendwie verstehen was blizzard gemacht hat
bei overwatch das ist mir das einzige was ich mir zusammenreimen kann ist dass man eventuell
zu sehr versucht hat auf dieser wir sind eigentlich ein casual game wo es mehr oder weniger ob
es reine just for fun spielen geht also außer dass sie eben versucht haben diese schiene
zu bedienen und gleichzeitig versucht haben ein auf hardcore e-sport game zu machen was
ihr auf wort für anfangen ich war also das muss man muss man auch mal klar sagen auf
wort hatte viele mechaniken drin die die schlicht ergreifend unfair sind wenn ich mir die ganzen
over time mechaniken am anfang angucke du konntest eine map verlieren obwohl du quasi
objektiv time hattest und sowas das ist so ganz ganz merkwürdig oder dann diese komischen
timings bei 2 cp wo du dazu gezwungen warst jetzt dich zu weit also dich dich sterben
zu lassen dein team dass du überhaupt eine chance hattest punkt 2 zu defenden oder umgedreht
dass du jetzt quasi gar nicht mehr attacken kannst weil dir ist einer beim attack gestorben
unter defender spawn ist bei anubis direkt um die ecke und sowas ich kann nicht wirklich
sinnvoll nachvollziehen was blizzard sich bei manchen sachen gedacht hat schon mitbekommen
mit ubisoft montreal ja haben wir uns schon angeguckt das letzte was ich gesehen habe
auf twitter ist dass sie gerade das haus evakuieren noch nix passiert ist oder was heißt noch
nichts ich hab jetzt so anders will ich das was passiert einer ich will nicht dass was
passiert ja also es ist nichts passiert bis jetzt ich hoffe auch nicht dass noch was
passiert ja
points von haut es war es war eklig ja also es hat sich nichts es hat sich in overwatch
leider oftmals so angefühlt als würdest du beschissen vom game und das ist eigentlich
eines der schlechtesten sachen was du haben kannst bei einem competitive game du musst
eigentlich also wenn es gut gemacht ist solltest du immer das gefühl haben du warst schlecht
und hast deswegen verloren oder du hast an irgendwas nicht gedacht oder du hast irgendwas
falsch gemacht und deswegen hast du auf den sack gekriegt so sollte das optimalerweise
in in solchen games sein in überwiegendem teil der fälle klar bullshit passiert in
jedem game mal aber in overwatch hat sie das gefühl dass sie gefühlt jede jede runde
du um irgendwas beschissen wurde das kann nicht sein das war nervig mit der zeit einfach
das haben sie bis heute nicht hingekriegt und ich habe auch meine zweifel dass auf dass
sie das mit overwatch 2 hinkriegen ich hab ich halte ja persönlich eh overwatch 2 dass
sie das da erst mal für den übelsten schnellschuss der auch überhaupt nicht so aussah als will
man ihn spielen das sei im prinzip aus als hätte sich eine gruppe modder hingesetzt
mit einem map editor und versucht ein paar overwatch singleplayer mission zu designen
so sah der trailer zu overwatch 2 aus also nichts was da irgendwie großartig hype generiert
ja aber wenn man sich anguckt die die overwatch league ist da ist gibt sie irgendwie noch
aber zuschauerzahlen sind kacke muss ich mal angucken dass auf overwatch liegt die
letzten spiele letztens und statistik gesehen die haben weniger zuschauer als irgendwie
so 08 15 cs tournament also ich rede jetzt nicht von in einem in einem riesen riesen
major irgendwie keine dreamhack oder so gibt es eigentlich intelex treemasters noch nee
das war eher starcraft ne davon rede ich ja gar nicht sondern von so von so normalen
irgendwelchen irgendwelchen frag mich nicht face it dinger oder sowas die haben dann
35 60 k 35 bis 60.000 zuschauer auf auf auf twitch und da hast du teilweise den offiziellen
overwatch league das ist jetzt ist hier level von overwatch drunter da denke ich mir halt
auch ok es kann halt nicht das ziel sein bei einer liga die mit so viel millionen da finanziert
wurde wo es millionen bei innen kostet es will keiner sehen im endeffekt und das ist
kein guter boden für großartige overwatch zukunft aber das blitz hat als meine man
ist voll selbstanschuld ja das ist nix was man irgendwie auf die spieler schieben kann
fanboys machen das gerne fanboys schieben sachen gerne auf die spieler so nach dem
motto ja kein wunder wenn alle spieler so toxik sind dass das spiel in bach runtergeht
nein der hersteller muss die rabenbedingungen setzen und ganz im ernst cs und gerade lol
ist auch toxik as fuck also man kann das nicht so rein auf auf die spieler jedes competitive
ist jedes competitive team game ist toxik as fuck im team untereinander wenn man nicht
regelmäßig miteinander spielt und selbst singleplayer spiele nicht singleplayer one
on one spiele wird auch oft genug rum geflamed also das ist nicht das ist nicht so in overwatch
mein overwatch war schon extrem toxik aber das spiel hat auch dazu eingeladen und das
hat blitz hat verkackt kann man anders sagen ja leute so ich gehe jetzt ins bett 22 22
wir sehen uns im nächsten stream machts gut bis denn zu